all right well yeah hopefully we are
live I guess we'll see it here ice cream
in just a second okay hopefully wherever
I do it something really exciting today
here with that back one guy Jennifer
take on a huge match here again yeah I
am Eric Rosen yeah it's gonna be a tough
match I played against him like a couple
of blitz games back in September here in
San Luis and it's gonna be a lot of fun
so it's gonna be a long match so four
games of ten minute each there eight
games three plus two and then ten games
one minute game one minute ten control
so yeah let's see what happens all right
I can't wait so we've challenged Eric
yeah I've challenged Harry he might be
setting up I think he'll probably be
streaming you can watch his side of the
commentary yeah in transom we also have
a special guest in the studio we keep
the studio doors open so any guests if
you want to come in yep let's get him to
accept and let's play this yeah I think
I already challenged him yeah 10-minute
games up this is a chess match people
know how chess matches work yeah so and
then I have this very special thing -
what do you have a keep okay who's
leading in this match so hopefully they
can see it looks a little little track
of the score here an etic one Magnus
Carlsen he beat Mike muscala Eric is no
joke two days ago two days ago in 1960
chess yes yeah it's 2960 he's also beat
um one of the other tournaments so you
see okay here we go
nine three and see what happens there's
a slight discrepancy in reading so he
beats you is rating this gonna be the
same like the first game 29.99
okay then I assume your rating is just
off the charts okay so I'm gonna go for
the Catalan then I saw he takes on c4
and then plays Bishop b4 check okay if I
understood correctly yeah he goes for
that and then c5 okay
I don't really don't remember this so I
think we should take see four and A
three was interesting here yeah a little
bit so the idea is just to force him to
take on a three and then I'll just
develop my night night I stayed three so
my idea is just to take on c4 back later
hopefully I can get this pawn back and
you know I'm gonna go short castle later
and then use this beautiful bishop on g2
is the best piece of the Catalan okay
sure castle nothing I can get this pawn
it takes before Queen b6 maybe yeah
gotta go for this and after Queen b6 I
think I can go short castle Queen text
before Queen d2 that looks interesting
because of the Queen takes Knight takes
d5 had no idea 9595 maybe doesn't work
so Queen b6 maybe 983 twin text before
Queen d2 here Queen takes and he goes
for b5
okay so I think Knight e5 Knight d5
nothing happens so hopefully I can play
some b3 here maybe let's see b3 looks
into three Oh also Knight c3 since he
cannot play a six but then Queen b6
Knight c3 looks interesting because
after will be 695 he can't go ninety
five but then he could go up here b7
nothing happens alright so I'm just
gonna go b3 here try to get rid of one
of these points C takes me three quick
takes b3
this is more or less equal position I
want to go share castle lady Knight c3
and then put some pressure and b5 that
looks like Lucky's doing fine 10-minute
games so no can never you know your
central oh yeah
so the rating for this Stein control is
also the same as blitz so that's why I
have you know about this he's gonna get
all my yellow points you know so he's
provisional so I wonder
that actually I mean whatever happens in
this first game is ratings gonna go up
like a bajillion points yeah like get
some any points at all okay we're
fighting for a three thousand right in
this game exact starting the day off
from the fight for three thousand all
right so now when I bring my Knight to
c3 or maybe to d2 let me think it's
going to be six probably all right let's
just hit below the pieces and then try
to go for rook e1 and E for something
like that or even ninety five could be
interesting Queen b6 active move alright
so but please now he hasn't got this
basics where for the nicer rook e1 rook
c8 looks very interesting okay hmm hey
Chris Edwards I am here reading the
YouTube chat so if you guys do have any
any questions or any comments you want
to tell us feel free to let us know on
youtube right so I'm gonna go for III I
was thinking about going [ __ ] one on
Danny for but then I realized this
default point can be a little bit weak
so got some ideas can bring even my
night to you
II won and then after Bishop takes King
Texas Knight can join the party by a d3
think d3 is a good square alright 91 we
should takes King takes or Knight takes
even looks interesting or I could just
try to go like group FC one fight you
for fighting for the c5 and all right so
92 maybe also protecting the the c4
squared looks good yes let's go 92
no 1 D 2 is not possible so I'm gonna go
92 we should takes King takes and then
later I wanna bring this Knight to b3 if
I manage to bring this Knight to b3 then
I'll be able to put some pressure on a6
later so he's gonna take this Bishop
which is very important but also a6 will
be a little bit weak in that position so
I have no idea what's going on here
position seems balanced
so let's see Pepe indeed he has many
fans online we're up to a hundred
eighty-seven people watching ooh that's
cool that's Phil yeah we're doing
fantastic you guys can ask whatever you
want to be on is gonna be here answering
all your questions in mostly distracting
Pepe as soon as you ask me like what's
his favorite animal there's something
silly then he'll be like he'll be in
time trouble I'll be asking to move out
you know my feels by animals or
something what's a little bit worried
that the screen has gone a little bit
darker all right so what should I do
here I'm gonna play King g1 there has to
be a good move so prophylactic move I
wanted to go tonight e4 but then there
could be some troubles in this diagonal
so for example now he doesn't double
rooks on the C file go 94 but probably
is gonna go for rook c8 I should do
something about this
maybe I could go Queen B - Queen B -
Queen c7 I like this move Queen B - yeah
so I free the square for the knight so I
can maybe jump to b3 but this d2 night
and then go to c5 and also I protect a
c1 rogue right so I could try to go for
example 94 also another interesting
blonde is root k3 Andrew k1 putting
pressure in a six but I don't know you
can't react like Prince on e5 at some
point but then I think d5 and then I
have a nice pass porn on the defiled so
looks more or less fine for me but you
never know so night b3 is interesting
then if I play Knight c5 hit text there
should be better somehow first
destruction serious question from pinch
Aniki you said that Bishop on g2 was a
great piece what did you exchange it
yeah because the bishop on b7 was - and
yeah a six could be weak alright so
Queen c7 I guess I got to go 92 he's
putting pressure on this c3 Knight so
I'm gonna go for 92 and now he exchanged
attack with my rook and then it's got to
go Queen b7 and then I don't know I
could play Knight b3 also he's not can
come to d5 so that's really nice square
for this night but he goes defy then I
have this e for square for my
- so 95 I could go 94 here probably wow
I didn't see rooks c2 here Roxy - looks
very interesting
Roxy - looks very very interesting goes
for that
holy hopefully he's not listening to our
stream I haven't found history I'm not
sure he's you can actually all right so
we will be three here can I go Queen b3
I don't know let me think
so Queen b3 look taxi to look takes c7
that looks good so I'm gonna go for
Queen b3 year let me think
yes Queen b3 so I don't like my position
I just missed her this route see to move
and now I put probably try to exchange
on scene - and then bring the other
route to c1 since he can't take on d2
because the rookin see it is unprotected
right so also his a six ponies hanging
in all this variation so he should be
taking in account that - and the good
thing is Knights really it doesn't have
they don't have nice squares for example
okay d5 is interested but then I think I
could go even 94 in that position 94 and
then you know I can jump to c5 okay the
good news for me it's I'm two minutes up
in the clock so that's always nice but
then I think it's got a nice nice
position he fights like two three good
moves I could be in trouble already in
this position so let's see let's see
also how do I remove this route from
here actually don't know for example I
can't move this night when he - since
then the rook takes e1 okay he took on
c1 and then I gotta - I'm gonna take
here on c1 he's gonna go to be seven and
now what should we do here all right
okay mm-hmm okay take here and then
maybe queen c3 or Knight c3 looks
interesting Knight c3 and then I want to
go 94 probably after Knight c3 is gonna
go Queen c6 there mmm
Christine grooms talking about I always
play on the platforms that give me the
highest possible ratings so also he's
getting you pretty good already
just 24 must be pretty weak this guy is
3,000 first of all he's not 3,000 at the
moment but yeah knocking on the door hmm
all right no Eric streaming as well can
you guys put like a Lincoln or something
me where's Eric screaming I just want to
make sure people have enjoyed watching
both your mother's things maybe I need
to refresh this or something before
Queen d7 I just had to refresh okay Eric
it's interesting to watch it on Twitch
I'm gonna go for so Queen d7 ePHI was my
idea Knight d5 Knight C to e4 and then I
could jump to c5 even though my d4 pawn
looks weak but also I have some nice
squares for example C 5 D 6 I don't know
what's going on here formats for him I
got six minutes a ghost Queen c6 yeah
gonzalo we're doing four games two ten
minute eight games of three plus two and
then ten games of 102 finish it off
alright so lots of Justice hmm
right f3 Queen d6 it's very annoying
there so II 5 night here 94 queen c1 I
don't like that to you
so probably keen f1 keen up one that
looks that looks good king of one yes
one Keaney 2 and maybe even king d3 just
protecting all my points where the king
there looks a bit risky but seal I don't
see how he's gonna put extra pressure on
my pond Saudi for honey for coming it's
six month and King e - let's try to
support my pawns for example now f3 king
d3 even though looks a little bit risky
but I think the king is doing a great
job there so this is the first game 7400
okay that was a good move hmm okay yeah
this is Game one can I take this night
and then or if I've to know he fights a
bad move so I guess I'm forced to take
here I could play King D three kings of
warrior king D three big warrior king
looks good King D 3 and then yeah one
let's break in d3 year so he takes I'm
gonna take back pre move I studied in
the Premier remove University so Knight
c3 context Queen takes King takes Knight
g4 f3 Knight takes h2 and then King d3
and the Nadi's son sir is kind of
trapped there on h2 so he goes Knight d7
and I think now I could be playing so
for example whom I don't like my
position so much d5 takes takes Queen C
for Queen B 5
okay let's go for this is so annoying
gonna play f3 here let's play f3
protecting everything for minutes for me
it's a lot of tension going on here guys
yeah this was a cattle and yeah this is
the cattle on you know slight edge for
white but nothing special
yeah maybe e5 is interesting there but
then I got the D Phi square for my night
I could've a jump there there's an a
fork on e7 so maybe I could try to go
something like 92 and Queen c2 exchange
Queens in the board here for example 92
looks good
and I want to go Queen c2 one fight for
the C file yeah Oh tricky so I can't
take there hmm
all right yeah take twice there's a poor
can be - yeah so let me think might be
one night be to my chemist Maura straps
on either four or even Knight c3 Knight
c3 Wow
looks like I'm gonna blunder everything
here they do it's a scary night c3
Knight beat you checking eetu nothing
happens right but then Knight B to king
c2 there I'm gonna go 93 and running out
of time so I should play fast here oh
let's see
Knight XE took in taxi to Knight takes
c3 okay I'm happy with the end game with
the king and game so it's not going for
that for sure then Knight B to ollie
move kingi to there and I think I'm not
blood or anything okay he goes back
there and now
right okay I'm gonna go night b1 I know
it's a ugly-looking move but life is
tough
Quinn day six now can I go 93
oh he's gonna take on V - gotta be
careful here that epic Queen c3 yes
let's protect everything there a knight
a four can I take night c4 I don't think
so because all right so let's go Queen
a1 here no no no no no cannot go for
that trouble
Travel for me a lot of trouble is now
after Queen b3 night XP nightly to check
I gotta go to maybe I can go to c3 well
sorry let's go play Queen be free there
might be two kings III it's only moved
there because if I go to eat - then
Queen takes e4 and suffering a lot in
this game I think I'm much worse now so
that's it it's never easy two minutes
per century with the reference from
Knight b6 he goes back now
Quincy 394 Queen b3 we are in some sort
of repetition because now I would love
to take on c4 he allows me context and
then King III I'm more or less solid in
that position
'if I've can I just take on c4 now can I
just take on c4 pawn takes King III on
9a for oops
very dangerous d5 I'm gonna take that
let's see what happens B Tech c4 King
III only move doesn't feel like we're
lagging nine a fourth and okay what
happens here Queen takes e4 I just
blundered this bone right mm-hmm
okay let's play Knight c3 here and try
to survive I don't have a lot of time
here one minute 40 seconds for him if
that's it look very good gonna go h4 and
Keena for and try to run away okay a5
[Music]
all right
so windy 1887 nothing happens
okay let's go age foreign I'm prey he
keeps pushing you keep pushing on in
some trouble but okay I'm gonna go g4g
five and then try to create some country
play over there dick Punk arrives to a
three and then one so Jamie - you can
find him on Twitch if you want to see
both sides
III I'm gonna go g5 here so it's going
to take I will take and then probably
and try to go some g6 trying to open
some lines for my queen to keep some
checks it's got one minute in the clock
I got one point 110 so let's see I
losing my fighting takes takes so how
does he proceed now 8th - I just take
the pawn Knight e4 which is external
check me okay 95 is interesting or not
so I'm gonna try to find out okay 95
Queen b3 and then kina for I run away
and then I got some pieces there so an
activity King f4 Queen 814 f5 I don't
know what's going on
kina v g6 kingi v to survive they're all
right so I'm gonna give some check here
on e7 he's got to go there now let's say
Queen d8 to threaten checkmate there so
Queen a tree I can go game a further so
King if I'd that was Queen is six now
King okay I gotta go there let me just
try to go there side they think this is
could be a troll this could be a draw so
okay I managed to save that game yeah
whoa that was there I could have been
worse second or worse yeah yeah yeah
alright so put this on the board special
board here yeah we keep it track here
all right squirt all right guys
I'm sweating like a beast now you know
so read the sign it says five yeah point
five okay so I just charged him again
so see you guys can see the on screen oh
we're back to black so yeah black now
we're predicting Paris or London from
Eric that seems to be what he is okay so
he's famous for yeah yes probably for
the London system his bed line and then
yeah let's see how do you trash the
place
see five here knight c6 Bishop d6 so I'm
gonna fight for the center for the e5
square yep normally people here play 92
and then c3 there right and then Bishop
d6 Bishop d3 Bishop g3 sorry sure Castle
and then there are several lines Bishop
d3 Bishop b5 okay okay so I'm gonna go
Bishop e7 this is an interesting line
just few games and now the threat is
night h5 also in threatening Queen b6 I
think I tree was not the best move
because Queen b6 the thing is forced to
take on c6 and he is forced to take on
c6 I guess I'm doing fine so let me just
at each other playing on just 24 if you
want to go there to see it slightly
faster than everybody else can I check
on I think I can take fresh take on d4
maybe I could try that
so take some d4 it takes a 6 ok I'm
gonna go for C takes all the load for
rosin in this chat
come on that phase a good man it's
alright yeah he's the loca
Eric's got his own stream go watch that
so a 6
I think he's forced to take now
otherwise the b2 pond is hanging so yeah
so he took and then I think this is a
good choice to take with this with the
b-pawn so now I'm planning to go see 5
or even a 5 looks
interesting a five here to develop my
poor bishop this fish was joining the
party by a six then tagged in the stroke
and f1 and then if I managed to play c5
then I think I'm a little bit better
because I got the bishop pair right but
life is never easy
so probably he'll try to stop that by
playing I don't know Quincy - now I see
his idea he is intended to go rook c1 in
one go so I can't play c5 thing after
Bishop a6 shook c1 I could try to go
rook F c8 and I don't see a way how he
can't stop that maybe Knight b3 there
but then for example Bishop c4 Knight d2
hmm not that easy so probably c5 is the
move just trade away so c5 then he's
taking their danger just take with my
bishop I got a nice bottom b4 for my
bishop - important question yeah I
actually support Betty's you know it's a
you know it's a decent team from Sabiha
because I'm from the south of Spain I'm
from Granada so yes one of my favorite
players is in Betty squawking it's very
funny and a very good player but I've
had to choose between bars on my three I
prefer Barcelona style you know that
style meta made us
world champions you know in 2010 we won
there this is so much about yeah you you
you you stole our name yeah I know we
like the one where you pass the ball
alright so I'm gonna go Bishop b4 here
protecting this guy is I managed to
bring this bishop out and then a route
to the C file I should be better but he
can try to stop the I don't know maybe
Queen c7 something like that but I think
still the endgame is fine for black soon
we'll see we'll see
who
yeah just get loads Annie most people
think they wait for me to start a stream
and then they just load me up with
emails that's the way it works see I'm
busy
all right so this Bishop is always
nightmare for the black player in the
Llano system yeah it's the best piece by
far so what are you gonna do Queen c7
maybe then I can take rook takes and
Bishop h6 still and then I bring rook to
ca got nice center here and then his
majority is not very good so Knight b3
probably he's trying to go to d4
something like that but then now the
efore square is also available for me
maybe after Bishop a6 he can try Bishop
c7 that's his idea
I think Bishop c7 so probably I'm gonna
go 90 for Bishop c7 Queen b7 something
like that
my knight is pretty active der so we'll
see what happens 94 Bishop c7 and I can
choose between Queen b7 Queen a7 or
queen a6 yeah we're good football we'd
like to kick it at the beginning we just
start using our hands cuz come on oh
it's too hard using your feet the whole
time I don't even understand the rules
so yeah we should watch the superball
together I follow a lot NBA um seems
popular actually I went to school do you
like basketball
well it just basketball was popular
there when I was there and okay yeah
yeah I got invited to some game we
couldn't go we got some good players
from Spain Gasol brothers and Ricky
Rubio Bishop e5
yeah he's tricky he's tricky
how about f6 here f6 Bishop d4 and then
Queen b7 something like that looks good
for me but Bishop a6 the same problem
Bishop c7 and then a 5 is just hanging
hmm okay let's play f6 here six Bishop
d4 and we're going Queen b7 probably and
now I will develop my bishop by a d7
probably and then he's got to be careful
about this
if I move which is which could be
interesting
so yes I'm gonna go Queen b7 now then I
think my knight is well placed on e4
when I go I 5 and then maybe he should
be six developing the bishop there
protecting d5 bringing a look finally to
the c5 maybe he can try Queen c7 there
my plan was to go just route b8 or
something like that 9 5 yeah come in
here
yeah our newest employee yeah so yeah
the cameras are here it's on the webcam
this is Abby
our newest employee yeah they're over in
the dark though yeah yeah normally it's
brighter both got the studio lights on
so get over here Emily Trask
yeah it's nice with these distractions
it's alright
what should they do the best the best
so there's yeah there's only 5
tablecloths plus the one that's in the
closet so there's we need four more if
you didn't find any area alright solving
problems alright ok alright hi Abby its
what they're saying Oh Cheers Evie
you're very popular hey guys come on
you're gonna dancing I should do it
behind the most people see come on I'm
just here to look for some chess piece
okay yeah they're in them
I came on right you might need the the
flashlight app should I do here sir
Knight takes Bishop takes rook f7 it
could be interesting takes Queen takes
the big thing start your own number of
yours yeah
377 just keeps growing that's really
cool
okay takes takes rook f7 all right let's
take here you should take now I get I
guess we should take C Phi and then
Bishop d7 d7 sorry thank its it's a
rightful black but maybe look at seven
it's interesting
hmm I'm wasting a lot of time here just
make an easy choice take here and then
Bishop d7 finally I got this piece up
but now I don't like so much where is
the coffee guy Dani for that
I'm glad the people they can read my
mind Nicolay he knows what I'm thinking
hmm let me bring my rook to c8
Erik come on be a nice guy I'm here
visiting you guys in the States
so he moved all righty-roo keys drink
coffee on it
he's got enough natural energy Queen c7
grew k7 all right let's go for that
route k-6 so probably it's going Queen
c7 and then my plan was to go route k7
way it forced a is she sucks you're
trending of course the shoe yeah
also rugby six is interesting a bouquet
seven it's forced to take a guess rook
takes b7 and then some pressure on b2 he
could place rook c5 though targeting the
a5 form but then I could bring the other
rook to e8 and still some pressure and
b2 pressure may for the King can come to
f7 at some point some if I move to I
don't know it's a lot of tension going
on in this game all right five minutes
you know these 10-minute games you know
I feel like I'm in a tournament already
and sooner right 3 3 plus 1 then sack
all my pieces and I'm blunder everything
and start another game what's the record
is it the people talking is it is that
the background noise we can we can shut
the studio door but it's so much fun
when people come in
all right where are you going Eric
you're going back you're going to see
seven I don't know if it are they
talking about it like a fan are they
talking about those people out there you
guys be quiet might just be the ledger
don't shut the door though we like you
sir but the door opens you guys keep
coming in very interesting Brooke c7
here that closed did you know Brooke c7
could be very interesting Queen takes B
to Queen a6 Queen a1 Kim h2 and then
he's got some pressure yes that was very
interesting
and now hmm should I do here so Queen B
a no bb-8 quintic c7 don't say stupid
things but so Queen takes b2 Queen a6
Queen a1 finished one Queen takes a four
but then Queen a7 Queen a7 is really
annoying their route d8 could be played
and nothing happens
I'm not so sure not so sure Knight d4 e5
win takes me to let me think
went a for Rookie 727 Group D 894 don't
like my position actually takes takes o
rook c8 yeah that looks good okay I'm
gonna take here and then root CA and he
goes through k7 I got rook c5 I guess I
shouldn't allow this route coming to the
C file would be extremely dangerous he
goes Knight d4 and now rook c4 maybe but
then b3 oh pretty annoying
preachy anoint you fine night before 95
takes takes you're not logged in that's
why you can't see the like people
oh no don't should I be some good steaks
I can sign it as myself uh-huh is there
just a bad stuff that I should be
blocking let's go if I hide me five
probably don't like my position I'm
forced to take here a takes and rook e8
I guess but starts looking not so good
I'm gonna go d4 to d4 I should have gone
TV fourth straight away yeah that was a
terrible move d4 takes takes rook c7 d3
I'm probably he can't stop that pawn he
can't stop the pond him before he's got
to go for takes takes d3
I'm gonna go for d4 here takes takes
rook c7 and then d3 takes in g7 tha drew
gate 17 g8 and then I think he can't
stop the D pawn so he should go forward
for the repetition there right it takes
it takes rook c7 I don't know if I'm
missing something in there but then d3
rook takes c7 and it's just probably a
draw let's see yeah number keeps going
oh my god
suffering a lot in these two games this
guy stuff yes that's really tall what
are the odds of I can I am being a GM
yeah
happens all the time depends on the I am
depends on the GM mm-hmm do you feel
like there's any big separation between
AIIMS and GM's should be something yeah
but not so much that's a vitamin yeah
this is the st. Louis chess club you
found us even watching on our YouTube
channel right now all right what's going
on I'm gonna go here King h8 just gonna
take on 87 King g8 and then he goes
through d7 I think I can go route d8
that was my idea
Luke the 8th so I had to play there Tina
fate only move and then after I'll give
you a series of checks oh my god I think
I'm just losing I think I'm just losing
group d7 rook da Luke h8 checkmate whoa
that's really seven-year if you have to
exchange it's very sad yeah I think I'm
going to lose group d7 is pretty pretty
good move here yes he found that so
probably I can resign already let me
think if I can fight a little bit more
but I didn't see this idea hmm
oh Rudy a checkmate so I got to take
here then yeah
ok let's try to fight though easy stuff
stuff this law games are you better at
the faster time controls hopefully
that's what we really pick it up so it's
got to go through t2 probably thanks 3
plus 1 okay I'm gonna go King g7 let's
say King g8
mm-hmm yeah rosin tough fighter all
right so I'm gonna try to survive here a
little bit
kingi five try to play some fast moves
you know five
check go back mm-hmm good go back there
we go it's good technique
kingi five then can I take this guy here
I think I can take that guy at age seven
and then eight seven group b8 I go back
and then I take that phone eight seven
could be taking check probably not
rolling just losing but okay just try
okay cheat too passive yeah mmm-hmm just
trying to hold this check go back no he
said nothing need to go back actually
it's really here for could have gone at
five there but still play that fast
pretty tough position for me okay that
move rook h8 g 4 can I take now maybe
even f5 f5 okay okay let's just move the
rope here f5 keen eight-six I'm probably
Kruk f7 just wins yeah shrub taking on
8th 7th still losing so still losing yes
very good
create here right and yes second reason
all right versus half I should start to
do something yeah with my pieces I'm
joking around my god okay bored bored
here this this encourages you oh yeah it
up just a little bit here I need a
window reading now like 4,000 what
happens you betta increase like 72 70
points so how is that it come on
where are you Eric is like Eric where
are you 10 minutes yeah yeah I challenge
you wait to see if I can see myself
holding up the sign there's a bit of a
delay but don't know if it's really
really up there
yeah people can't read that broadly but
oh I see my friend I live from guru life
isn't talked to her doctor they give me
the black pieces again right so I think
this is not yeah come on starting to do
it now all right let me just challenge
with my policies okay ten minutes okay
Eric says he hasn't heard challenge on
the chess 24 don't worry leave des
yeah it's a little much so still like 19
games more yes sir or 20 games more whoa
we got a ghost piece all right
efore let's see what he plays c5 I think
it plays the accelerated dragon so I
know okay he goes for a six
I'm gonna go d4 let's see what kind of
Cicilline plays the time an awfully then
Queen c7 Bishop e3 I'm gonna go this for
this line Bishop d3 not the main line
but pretty interesting so short Castle
then people takes their and we should
see five I'm gonna go Bishop e2 here
black normally plays d6 and then my idea
is to take an f6 and then play Queen d2
there are many many interesting ideas
for example black gosh King is 7 Bishop
d7 okay do I remember something enough
we got this mm-hmm we should be seven
right okay so I'm gonna go drew k d1
this looks like a decent move then there
are some tricks in these positions
wouldn't be six okay can I go Queen f4
when a floor looks natural here Queen f4
King is seven once we go Bishop d4
probably right I'll go Queen a four here
so attacking the f6 pawn probably it's
gotta go be some d4 there but then roopd
three sometimes it's the idea t3 it's
the idea sometimes you should be 4 and
then route d3 Bishop e5 he goes long
castle
pretty aggressive move by Eric alright
so probably got to defend this pawn
Queen f6 Queen takes b2 and then
right so I'm gonna go be three here just
protecting my pieces and then think what
happens so Bishop d4 route d3 was my
first idea Bishop e5 I can go always to
h4 it's going to bring a rope to the G
file at some point and yes he saw it
it's also got to defend this f6 pawn
right eric is streaming as well you can
go find him on Twitch go back and forth
get both sides yeah all right okay so
hey grant chest plaits bishop d4 right
so Luke d3 I guess is a pretty natural
move he goes Queen c5 I can always go 91
this is a typical money over in this
position don't wanna blend or anything
but typically Castle queenside sorry
this black typically castling queenside
no not really so maybe he prepared that
normally the King stays on e7 because he
sits pretty solid there and then you
protective six but it looks like a very
interesting idea okay so root key 8 now
I'm gonna go for maybe 91 91 this is a
very typical move here so you wanna
maybe go c3 and then when the bishop
comes to e5 there's green h4 and the
bishop sometimes could be trapped there
so keen edge 1 followed by f4 it's an
idea and dispositions whenever he goes
Bishop b5 I could try to go see four
right okay I can also protect from the
third ranking I let's say it's on route
g3 at some point if needed
and probably is gonna try to double
rooks on the g5 route g6 route g8 at
some point but then let's see what he
does with this Bishop from different cut
it could be in trouble sometimes
all right group g6 so for example
Queen h4 or c3 Bishop e5 I could play
maybe Queen III King if he looks very
very interesting there cuz then I'm
threatening f4 in that position so I'm
gonna go for that
c3 yes
c3 probably his it's going back to e5 he
can't go to see if I because there's
before and now I would love to exchange
some Queens
since this bishop could be in trouble
but then mmm let me think because after
23 he can't take and then Bishop f4 I
can't just go back to d3 and then try to
play some g3 ideas yeah okay
let's eliminate the Queen's yeah I think
Eric is streaming alone I don't think me
being here though actually is it help to
Pepe I'm just here to distract him so
giving you know a little bit cap here
yes reading your comments exactly
encouraging people to come in the room
make lots of noise you know yeah you
guys should visit the st. Louis chess
club just so amazing well these people
have built here you guys are around just
come play some plates with me and
Jonathan yeah but again I'm leaving
tomorrow
so hurry up
I'm my flight back to Spain tomorrow so
what should I do now check with my rook
or with my knight if I take with my
knight Bishop f4 9410 maybe Bishop b5
it's pretty on there so taking with my
rogue could be an idea Bishop f4 route
d3 back ok Knight takes Knight takes
Bishop f4 I could just go back to to d1
for example ok let's just try - alright
she goes Bishop e5 and then I'm gonna go
see for here probably it's going back to
c6 now can i play f4 that's my question
here can i play there for looks looks
like a good move
looks like a good move f4 f4 Bishop
takes pawn takes Bishop takes Bishop
takes and looks like black white is
better so it probably should go up you
should be too there and then you should
f3 probably should a three all right I'm
going for that f4 Bishop b2 I think it's
the only move here if I didn't
but underneath a bishop efore takes
takes takes and then whites better I
guess
so it's gotta go to beat you there and
my idea is just to play Bishop f3 and
after Bishop e3 just maybe keen f2 one
king e 2 then I want a double rooks on
the D file and then put some pressure on
this witness these six they're also some
nights each one be four ideas
kickin this Bishop from there soon okay
let's improve our pieces Bishop f3
Bishop a3 probably oh ah route B 1 was
I'm threatening roughly 1 followed by B
4 so I think he's forced to go to to a3
now and now maybe King F 2 followed by
King e 2 looks very natural to me going
for this skin f2 right yet it's very
brief kingi - let's see what happens not
pressure on the G file for example night
c2 or ruk FD one looks very very natural
now Knight C 2 followed by b4 that's my
plan let's see if I can do that I think
take a first step
properly explained Tino's question yes
asking why I've I've stopped the opening
videos ok what happened it's in
relationship to getting a promotion
ok Knight see - he can try to stop that
by playing a 5 at some point there are
so many tactics here going on like some
f5 Bishop left 85 at some point to f5
looks interesting but I think he can
just play rock g5 something like that
nothing serious happens there
so probably g3 is interesting here I'm
gonna go g3
so I can try to go some Bishop h5 moves
also night c2 an ID for maybe you can
try to open the position by playing a
four but then my idea is just to go
tonight c2 and then try to play some
some b4 so I'm gonna go night c2 here
prophylaxis against a force so now can
be met by by b4 and get specifically
dryness hey Ryan
he's got plenty of time come join us how
we're doing
no great yeah what I'm losing what we're
waiting for the speed that's what we're
really gonna shake exactly that's the
only thing I can do here so he's up yeah
about 260 people can air accurately I
hope not but I mean what else could be
stream sleeping us no wonder you clean
so well but I know I doubt it we're not
really watching him is not watching us
yes
well yeah this stuff here's our there's
a board we can refresh the people
unhappy face on Herrick yeah where's the
marker here here due back here I see you
kind of tried to play but Eric doesn't
have to deal with this
he's sitting there focus who's trying
he's trying to start us he's not fair
yeah yeah oh yeah just hold out there
for the next three six
I'm gonna go h4 here voice a group doing
there so holy Luke g6 back and now I got
some progress wait sorry to say that you
have to my g3 pawn actually so maybe I'm
forced to go here g4 I don't want to do
that without playing us inside let's go
d4
so b5 looks to me like a very good move
here I'm really scared about this beef I
move b5 and then okay maybe I gotta go
93 there Bishop takes King takes pawn
takes pawn takes and it's not that
serious because he always has this
weakness on d6 and also maybe my next
move could be group t8 now 8th feet
looks to me like a very interesting move
for them
b5 or I could try to go something like a
4 what am I supposed to do here
94 hmm a 3 B 5 tennis the rows in the
building he didn't want to come in the
room when I gave him a chance but I got
big friend of Dennis LaRue from Walnut
California joining us in the chat hmm
all right egg for the board larger maybe
okay I don't want to play a four but the
thing is playing B 5 in the next move if
a 3b five could even be worse so I think
I'm forced to play a four here I don't
like that move but I felt like kind of
forced to do that and now let's see I
kind of proved my knight for example
like 94 or 93 and I want to attack this
Bishop from C fights not the least
attack tossed oh so I'm gonna go Knight
d4 here 94 93
let's just play 93 and see what happens
g5 could be an idea here to open the
eight files so maybe he's getting ready
to kick in the center with f5 in this
position
so probably g5 f5 that's his idea all
right
so can I go something like king d to
bringing the king this part of the board
I'm not so sure I'm gonna go for that
yeah King D 2 on King C 2 looks very
risky everything now
Luke a8 let's say King C 2 now Luke t 8
probably I can't go now g5
can I go g5 he got is going f fight
there so okay I'm gonna go rook F 1 here
you see that we are playing a lot of
nonsense here look at mas g5 let's go
let's go g5 well escort I'm gonna do
something in this position so if F takes
I think I could go F takes yeah
half point for Pepe what did they have
for Eric F takes F takes and then eight
six looks like a very good move there
this is getting crazy I don't know guys
this bishops could be extremely
dangerous at some point so don't take
spawn takes eight six and then a goes
eight six straight away
can I go 94 here 94 and in context
Knight f6 that should be interesting in
the placed 94 here or even taking on f6
route g3 oh I don't know I don't know
okay I'm gonna go 94 here let's go 94
it's jarring to see Pepe speak English
yeah it's it's not speaking right I'm
realizing how tough is to speak in
English and play at the same time with
the software in front so me talking next
he was so 94 H takes that was a good
move how about nine eight six is willing
to sacrifice the exchange I guess
magtec's Knight takes looks very
where you're known for me actually so
okay I think it's the only way
96 G takes f for night xe8 Luke take c
8h 5 and run and pray I think that's the
only thing I can do here
yeah that's my kind of calculation h5o
be strong that week boof Luke h1 that's
my idea if it goes rook g3 but then rook
takes a thrill looks like a very good
move there so ii 5 should i run run run
run my friend come on be strong that
weak run eight-six gotta make it two
squares two more squares buddy
eight seven then Luke 8 1 Rudy - Rudy -
roopd a that's my plan let's see if it
works or not
Luke g3 just 87 root K 3 root H 1
nothing happens so I guess I got to play
Luke h 1f v Wow is getting wild mmm-hmm
takes e4 and
yeah that was very good then I go to
defy looking at this I don't want say
because it's giving back to exchange so
Bishop takes it takes pawn takes Bishop
takes here's a pawn up actually I think
if I can count correctly but then my
point is only seven right seven yeah now
this is change again exactly Monde gotta
get there okay okay I'm gonna take that
with your permission and then let's say
King d3 followed by King e4 probably and
then I want to go 8 7 root 8 7 that was
a good move
that was a good move maybe f6 and Bishop
c4 that looks good maybe it's a draw I
want to see if there's something else
like kimmy14 f6 and then I can't improve
my PC so I think I have to I have to go
for this Cain f6 and Bishop b4 and then
eight seven and please my pony's there I
don't know if it's going to work but
Brooke eight six it could be a second
Facundo
probably first I could improve the
position of my kin
maybe Keaney - Keena three I see what's
what's he's doing so I was about to go
route g1 don't do that don't do that
baby
so let's say Bishop f5 we should be fine
oh great look at fate I don't know
what's good here it's really good I'm
gonna go rogue aged five and seven see
what happens
kingi - probably and keen f3 well this
position is there's so much tension
going on here no clue so let's say kini
to Bishop g3 keen f3 and alright so
route g5 was interesting here look g5 is
interesting let's go for rook g5 check
King kinder and then king f3 you've
proven the position I'm liking this coin
the skin is coming to eight six maybe if
I have time for that
let's say King g4 here teenage five it's
my next move
come on we're almost there buddy teenage
v f3 rook at five and then drew takes f3
we are almost there buddy come on run
run like a beast kin eight six days f3
come on check and then gonna take this
guy here and alright nothing happens
King g4 Rukh eight trees my next move
alright ruk a tree probably is going to
h8 with the king he managed to save the
position a little bit so now gotta be
careful maybe Bishop d2 it's about a
good move okay rook c6 rook c7 route c6
let's go for this route c6 now he's
planning to go rook F for so I'm gonna
go Bishop f5 then probably up c5 rook c7
improving my pieces so keen f3 rook F a
tankini for God good pieces got good
pieces let's say rookie 7 then rook d7
let's say Luke f7 so now when I go
Bishop e6 in that position and then
bring my king let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go efore give me that
give me that give me that
KYNA 5 king g6 we're almost there look
at 5 now I want to take there maybe I
don't know let's say rook f7 rook d7 I
don't know what's my plan okay I'm gonna
take this guy here and hmm come on Pepe
too weak to stop king g6
rookie 798 yeah that's a move yes
checkmate
all right tough to win a chess game oh
my gosh that was intense
what's up - Julien
Julian they go Oh master all right
no I got some confidence yeah yeah one
1/2 1/2 that's it they turn around now
we have to face the London problem right
yeah London's he said again but I think
I like the previous position that I got
so I'm gonna try to repeat that line he
goes for Bishop b5 all right
d4 Knight f6 and Bishop f4 probably
that's his pipeline so not just
everything Julian says very strong so
far all right let's go 45 here then c5
or even a 6 whatever you see that finish
Dani
oh yeah we're crushing it now ok back in
business
mentally though Network crushing them
all right b6 no short Castle you should
be fired was played before now Bishop d3
is a main line and then after b6 e 4
it's a crazy line and the main line goes
after 95 I guess ok it goes for the same
line now I'm gonna go up again Bishop e7
yeah it's funny so I went to one of his
lectures here it wasn't recorded but he
was talking about this Bishop e5 line
and how it is and then you know you just
thought that they don't play Bishop to
e7 which is actually on your radar yeah
so he's probably upset that you know all
right
so b6 there's the secret
London's calling so now sure castle
Bishop be 795 a thing I can just take on
e5 and then 94 I think that's where I
prepared but okay let me in the chat
nothing will never live up to the hide
that blitz bounty with Dennis the real
pretty good yeah that was a very good
match exactly an excellent commentary
all right so now what do we play here
sure Castle f4 this is what the people
do here I know so now that takes pawn
takes Knight e4 thing I can go for this
no the main line is with the bishop on
d6 okay all right I'll just take and
then 94f takes I guess 94 I got some
bishop aged for ideas to only somehow on
this line I always put my 997 and then
the bishop takes on h7 and I just lose
yeah 94 so he takes e4 Bishop c4 I guess
I can play their Bishop age 4 also if
the bishop comes to see 4s on drug CI
threatening sea taxi for in that line so
let's see and this is the last boring
game like 10 minutes game then we'll go
to 2 right let's time control 3 plus 2
he can't figure out how to beat us again
it's only gonna get tougher and tougher
my friend yeah and it's actually
difficult to adjust to blitz after this
10 minutes camps you telling me to stop
talking but that would be you know kind
of yeah come on I think that's that's a
whole - driven advantage I'm not here
distracting you
all right so what should I do night sexy
- looks like like a normal move here
then maybe f5 or some dodgy six followed
by f5 I don't know
98 c3 is his first attack with the palm
but he's got a really dangerous attack
there soon
how about if I just take on d2 then g6
yeah I'm gonna go for this
alright Knight XE - and can I take home
d4 here so to give a check on the G file
on the own g5 sorry so she takes pawn
takes Bishop g5 check Bishop h4 and then
I can't take and then play f6 something
like that I don't know also g6 is
interesting h4 gonna take here nikon d4
paula is going to take with the e pawn
and now my plan was to go Bishop g5
check g5 check let's go let's go
Bishop f4 and I guess I'm forced to take
there on f4 h5 no quick taxi five right
so I think I have to take there and now
f5 could be interesting here f5 or even
f6 even f6 looks really interesting
there but also f5g for I don't know
what's going on here I'm gonna play f5
and then see what is last day here so
yeah I'm going back I said I'm on
Hamilton will be here starting tomorrow
Canadian right yeah yeah chess Brown
Eric Hanson I'm in Hambleton all right I
should create some code to play now I
don't know how but I should do like
maybe B 5 B 4 looks interesting he's
going for g4 I know I know Eric he's
going for g4 there so probably g5 g
fibers could be interesting or maybe
it's just too much maybe it's just too
much a5 a5 is interesting so after g4
Bishop a6 was my plan so if gtx a5
Bishop takes c3 followed by rook f5 so
now this bad bishop
love to exchange that you know like if
he allows Bishop 86 and I think black
would be in good shape
because I could create some contemplate
b5e for later and I think it's attack is
not that fast
let's see and probably he could play
something prophylactic like Luke f2 or
something like that Bishop f6 Bishop c2
could be an idea he goes g4 straightaway
Wow
alright so I think I'm forced to play
Bishop a6 here takes takes and one takes
rook takes the rook is a little bit
misplace your an a6 whatever you want to
play do you know where any more of these
would be there should be a couple in the
closet is there we got that empty
there's like oh and now and now I wanted
to go Queen g5 check that looks at least
interesting so rubgy 525 takes takes
rook f2 he would be threatening to dowel
rooks on the F file and then Luke a8
rook F 1 that looks good to me so I'm
gonna go for this
I think I have no other choice the Rho
kinase a is just terrible place all
right let's go Queen g5 Queen takes rook
takes and now probably rook F 2 followed
by rook F 1 looks very good
yeah there should be some streams with
them on so stay tuned during his
residency we always try to get the geums
know oh I see an idea now I can try to
go after rook a to look at five takes
takes rook F 1 g6 Kimmi three king of
1704 and who knows what's going on there
alright I'll try that my wife is wishing
you good luck okay thank you awfully
what's it mean
Alexis Alexis Alexis
okay Thank You Alexis that's like a
Greek name yeah okay last name I love I
love Greek food you know
it's just so good this jido Santa Tiki
it's great I have no clue what's going
on in this end game could be extremely
dangerous for me maybe he's got some c4
ideas too if I take there are two really
dangerous pass pawn in the center I
don't know man you know we called the F
phone in Spanish
Facundo so let's see I could try B 5 so
the rook is really active from this six
square all right
so g5 Luke do you find it looks good
g5 rook f1 g5 maybe h4 that's pretty
annoying okay I guess I have to go teen
f7 kina four and then g6 they're
probably later b5 and then I could try
to go some B for some point the route
comes to c6 before try to open the C
file try to get some Connor play no clue
what's going on our journey but Tina 46
h4 looks interesting the list for what
we call the H bond we don't have only we
have fun dough Carlitos yes I know they
talk and then we have our is totalus you
know it's okay well great philosopher
from game and respawn yet but we should
baptized let me take that but this is
just a lot of mess going on here so
Keaney 6 takes takes rook e1 drew k7
that could be interesting for me I don't
know I'm gonna go for this Keaney six
takes on d5 takes root g1 Luke a7
finally this route comes into the action
who knows maybe I'm worse I never could
have resisted taking this upon yes all
right now g5 could be a move but then
takes takes rook c7 I shouldn't la de
rue k7 c 5 c 5b 5c 667 I don't know man
I'm gonna go rook a7 and then pray see 5
B 5 okay he goes he takes and then king
takes and I want to go g5 + f4 at some
point probably rook c8 is a good move
rook c8 probably is a good move
then aiming to go rook da check
so I'm gonna protect this skin by
playing group d7 here and now my idea is
to go g5 + f4 if he allows that I don't
know and then start running with these
pawns
come on guys do your job
he's wrong that week dude your job rook
b8 looks good for him
but then Cain c6 okay he protects he
attacked my [ __ ] doe so what should I
do here jisuk King e6
Kimmi 6 rookie 8 kindy v e6 group D 6 e
7 check and I might be losing alright so
what then is godrick f6 they're pretty
dangerous stuff here going on
hmm all right g6 rook f6
hmm Kunis oops okay let's go for this
line but then droopy eggs it's pretty
annoying I feeling I could be losing
already real tight up one and a half to
one and a half yeah
Group B ed looks looks good for him oh
my god for kingi for F we know it's just
losing all right just try to save this
mm-hmm F for kini for right seven in d5
gotta start running okay keen d5 and
then G 5 and then okay let's go
g 5 let's go Group B 5 kini 6 Luke takes
a 5 and he gets another pump doesn't
look very good
King C for Luke takes a 5 or even Roxy 5
first
so no that's a look good man very good
yeah I'm gonna lose this game too
[Music]
all right
rage five here there's no hope actually
rue k-6 candy five you can even try to
to get all those phones rotate six or
something like that
three minutes for Eric now I threatened
him F for actually about some it's not
that easy
GRU k5 probably is the best move then
kini six and then let's see how improves
my thing he can just run with the with
the white pawns before something like
that he's got two minutes till a lot of
time okay five Kinsey for King see if I
group before my cane is far away he's
sick so shouldn't go away from the
center
maybe group these six wins I don't know
okay let's go figure it out all right
how about age for death and then G for
let's go age four and then a five G for
a six g3 should be losing for me but
you're all in so yeah what can I do
G for and now a six F for or takes g3
takes a tree a seven
yeah a six the ponies tooth yeah
Rosen started on a brand new account so
ratings Tony I gotta go King c7 there g3
come on
what happens here one will happen six h3
let's go
hey treat aji cook you know unfair I can
resign alright two and a half versus one
on her yeah
okay so now three three plus two you're
not gonna play fast are you good at
three two that's like the most prefer
I'm not good at anything you know time
control what about one oh that's what it
really matters we got 10 1o games coming
yeah exactly in ten of those I'm pretty
slow so I better score here otherwise I
will be in deep trouble over it is what
he's up to
he's playing like commercials and stuff
for his people
okay yeah that's good hopefully he's
making it making big bucks
how did I lose this game 25 was not
probably the move for maybe Bishop a6
there no I felt like I have a good
position okay
even when you traded the works under
five did you feel like dang games should
be good feel no well I think Ruka fire
was a mistake I should have played Roux
ke8 and then played that position
because I got an active broken g5
whenever he goes rook f7 I got rook G to
check so probably that was a big mistake
look at five
damn I'm already stressed up too man me
too I know imagine if you had to
actually fight Oh Jesse
so I see every game it's been a battle
this has been intense so far okay three
plus two eight games
hey there hoping for a slightly bigger
board do you want the board bigger or do
you like it I I'm fine with everything
no I think what they they are scared is
just to capture another screen just the
board and not the results the bulbs or
stuff like that so here we go okay we
were a typical set of them so it's like
okay doesn't matter so I'm gonna play
okay let me think
gonna play d6 here Jesus yeah I wanna
stop playing against yeah yeah we can
make a bigger
all right okay matter of six this is the
philidor's if I one of my favorite
openings so nice level here we gotta
leave it as it is okay
you should see form a line g4 is very
interesting goes for Bishop c4 Bishop e7
short Castle sure Castle and rook e1 or
a4 are the main moves c6 a me to go b5
so a force necessary and now basics a
trip then I go a six here
the plan is to go route B 8 and b5 is
not a big deal
alright so Ruby a watching a bubble or
something minutes
I don't know but yeah if you hold the
ctrl and then you do that scroll thing
again yeah but yeah I think let's wait
for the next game okay we don't mess you
up yeah and then okay I'm gonna go 98
and 97 try to go some b5 move it's not
gonna be easy
alright let's go Knight c7 year or even
Bishop g5 looks very good looks very
good I want to exchange that Bishop so
yes
Bishop g5 right exchanging his best
piece night c4 putting some pressure
there but then I think it's not that
problematic I got everything protected
so g6 looks good
intend to go f5 at some point
okay now I'm gonna take there and think
Queen g5 could be a good move there
Knight c4 dang game what it's not a game
so we've entered the the second segment
here so this is the first of eight games
of three two and then after that we'll
move on to ten games of one oh yeah I
guess actually I'm a little bored here I
should make some sort of division g3 all
right how about the f5 here
f5 looks very good at five
can I go can I do this I think so
because of the next he can never take on
a fight with an idol something because
the Queen on d2 is hanging so eight take
c5f fights or gtex f5 and then I will be
threatened to go something like a for an
f4 so okay he goes for eight four very
interesting moves so queen eight six
interesting so the Queen on d2 is still
unprotected so now I would love to go
some f4 and close the position over
there and try to start some sort of
attack on the King side given the fact
that he has played age four so now f4
could be very very interesting as he
takes an f5 t takes a five and now
probably something like Knight to c4 but
ghost rook to d1 and now could I go f4
here f4 looks very very interesting F
for a knight c4 probably also e4 looks
good
if four followed by a ninety five right
so let's go for this oh my god 95 should
be an idea so 95 Queen sexy 297 keen f7
rook takes King seven and it looks like
I get the piece back so but I should be
really really careful with all these
moves I should be really really careful
with Knight f5 now I'm going to go
Knight e5 so threatened Knight f3 so
it's got to do something about this
probably f4 is very interesting in this
position aiming to you know to bring
some pieces
f4
also Queen to g6 looks very good here
Queen to g6 let's go for this move or
also f4 f4 like looks crashing but it's
not that easy
it's never easy this game you know when
I broke wing g6 I want to bring my other
Knight to f6 and then hopefully at some
point Wow I didn't see that move it's
pretty annoying 92 not f6 probably
Knight f4 there and how about something
like Queen f7 Queen f7 then Bishop
H okay we never looks good still
position is pretty unclear and alright
let's go
b5 here so takes takes and then I don't
know I could even bring the Bishop to d7
later but then he's got a file open so
maybe that was not a very good idea
for me so I'm gonna go keen h8 don't
want any troubles in this day I don't
know it's got 130
all right so route b6 or would be 7 I
felt like it screwed up Rigby 794 could
be interesting too okay so let's go
Bishop d7 now Queen takes rook effect
Queen takes a lot of tension in this
position okay what should I play here
for example Knight g4 looks good I think
he can take everything alright so how
about Queen g8 first in the issue so
it's got to take there and Queen f8 so
like yeah
a lot of tension going on here Quinn
effect retakes okay six bring pressure
on d6 I could be in trouble I'd say not
have seven is good moves
yeah he's praying really strong it's not
fair when they place yeah man
96 nothing happens through key eight so
go back when I go back or not oh I
didn't see that coming then trying to
take this pawn here boo-boo k8 rook b8
and worse of course I'm much worse here
I had so nice physician the story of my
life yes small you know story of my life
all right so whoo-wee b8 don't do that
baby don't do that move and play that
move how about Mookie five here
kick this night back from that five
maybe he's got some tricks did it looks
like there are a lot of tricks here
going on so I'm trying to find them yeah
okay let's go see four said there's no
Queen B five now it's gotta go to Queen
probably is Queen d2 it's like a good
move there
Bishop h3 all right so let's play ping I
ate here so to protect now when I go
rookie's seven finally kicked this route
from there so after Queen d2 rukhi seven
this rook is not so active anymore so
Ruki seven okay he goes rook c7 whoa
some nasty threats rook c8 is his threat
so probably Wow Luke c7 very very
interesting this guy's so annoying
maybe rook c5 here rook c5 takes takes
and I wanna centralize my pieces rook c5
d takes e5 and then this night can join
the party by E 5 ok he doesn't want to
exchange some pieces so let me just go
what should I go here okay rook if I
forget woof
when I go rookie 7 come on go away
come on jump i blundered upon on d6 this
is just so ridiculous it's just so
ridiculous so ridiculous it takes okay
let's play Queen f7 I'm running out of
time here I just bought her everything
yeah oh my god
if I don't fight on move any random oh
no no no I'm just playing terrible just
not gonna work out okay what's the story
cuz they keep complaining okay like that
yeah if you won't control in the ring
okay what am I going to play Knight yeah
that's it look good that's it look very
good a little bit bigger display there
ready one of my favorite openings it's
not working out so Knight c3 in order to
stop a 4 after d4 I can go to be 5 or 2
a 4 both are interesting so let's see
it's alright guys you didn't miss that
for at some point people are talking
about it what's looking very very good
and what's not watching at the point so
night be five nights e6b should be to e3
all right let's try that night be five
nights e6 probably Bishop v2e five III
and then I don't know let's play Bishop
b2 b5 is force here and then III so
first in the issue probably it is God
this Bishop c5 move here or it's too big
now get out of it all right
even 95 looks really interesting there
so Bishop c5 95 95 it takes d4 and that
could be an interesting idea but their
thing he's got 93 there
alright so Bishop g4 I'm gonna go a tree
but then take stakes I just go back
right so a tree looks good dr. Terry
time will make it way too big way too
small somewhere in the middle Bishop f3
Bishop e3 e4 Bishop g2 and then there's
still a lot of pressure going on on the
d4 pawn so I guess if he goes back to h5
I can just play g4 there and after
Bishop d6 it takes d4 and I get that
point for free so takes takes Bishop c5
and now I guess it's not that easy
it's never easy this game I hate this
game
all right let's play Bishop g2 back so
prophylaxis against key for now I could
probably continue with something like
Queen c2 or even a three let's see for
example I can even take there but then
Knight takes Bishop b7 I guess okay I'll
take on d4 he takes it for my ideas just
to play d3 there no okay no yeah just
that the three to segment started like
so if you take with minor pieces he the
the pot ambition was hanging so all
right let's go d3 here and I should be
careful with my knight on d5 at some
point they could be it's on c6
going on but okay yes let's play a three
so he retreats it's Knight to e7 there
could be some b4 ideas also so exchange
this plan for the central pawn on d4 and
for example now yeah 95 could be a move
it comes through key eight and now
probably Queen d2 it's interesting so
just when I fight for the e-file for
example look F 2 e 1 or root K 2 e 1
could be interesting if he goes now to
e7 with the night Amy to go c6 then
before should be should be should be the
move there for white so and also the a5
phone is hanging so yeah I like my
position I got the bishop pair but still
it's tough it's tough see you like pea
but I love pie you know I don't know how
to go dad you know I'm terrible at the
kitchen but when other people make it's
really tasty so how you tried paya here
yeah ah you were starting in the Madrid
you told me yeah
through the University she got
you know some sort of rent from the
University and then university charged
me and somehow they're making all the
money
mm-hmm well yeah she'd make she had to
like make us dinner every night or
something that was part of the agreement
just to put us up and make us dinner yes
I'd love to pie yeah
great so what happens here yeah that's
one distract eewan is gonna say six give
it up
hmm
give me that well how about f4 here f4
that goes for Knight goes and then I
don't know what's going on okay let's go
yeah you see he can actually take on he
can take on c4 and the position is very
very interesting for him but he cost
Knight is T 6 now I think I want to then
that's fine we're approaching time
trouble so you know time travel
rooks e1 we're approaching it well he
takes rook takes it's got this III
squared which is very annoying it's
extremely annoying but then I can take
everything and then goes on c6 terror
let's see let's see rookie 3 looks very
annoying coaster I know the tension
97 all right
g4 I don't want you to go to f5
it's got 30 seconds this should be good
for us but then I'm too weak to slow my
god don't talk like that we're stronger
come on we're strong today
motivation is a fun thinking motivation
a point isn't if a point is hanging yeah
now Knight d5 I can get that you should
be able to get that ringing Dan 96 not
possible so I'm gonna go rookie one here
okay the pawn on c5 is hanging in so
don't blunder prepare gonna go rook c1
protecting my pawns 14 seconds come on
give me that which should be 5 so
where's the swing going probably to d7
or something like that
got nice pieces for example d4 and then
he's got to jump to d5 probably then I
want to go f5 here winning some space
there enroller and then probably Bishop
d6 looks good for me looks very good so
I'm gonna grab another one give me that
96 ok I gotta go back to you d2 then
he's taking on e5 probably but then
after pawn takes nothing really happens
so Bishop d6 now putting pressure there
now mm-hmm okay d5 where are you going
it's got to go back probably to e7 but
now I think this should be winning
somehow give me that and d6 probably
rook e1 come on I should have missed
this but anything can happen here you
guys know that means it's free
protecting everything so now I'm gonna
go f6 probably okay okay I'm gonna go
you should be 5 here putting pressure on
f7 takes takes now probably okay for but
then rookie for nothing happens all
right so where are you going because
they went for you're going to h4
go f6 here quinny-quinn takes here and
this end game should be completely win
take it and then d7 and that's it right
okay he's got kin afraid
yeah but then this end game should be
winning rook e8 or even a four first a4
first takes takes e5 or Kim f2 that Sam
of cleanup - yeah keen f2 and then rook
e8 and that endgame should be completely
won yeah take stakes and let's say Queen
King III King efore and Tina five and
now a four f5 check yeah this is winning
yeah alright support okay not that easy
f6 a5 a6 and Kim D six and what's
winning all right came to at the 3-2
section but we get we got eight of these
total we've got six more Sun right yeah
we got three to three tar eyes all right
back up so again d4 probably yeah kind
of thing what to do about this line I
got the antidote don't worry oh yeah
should I play King's Indians should I go
for the same line I think I'm getting
nice positions okay not this Knight f6
and then I'm going to go for the Kings
Indian probably her let me think at 35
now come on let's play the the main line
you won't play something different I can
okay no no I'm playing the same the same
lurid same really the recipe should be
working on them should be working
you should be seven a tree again
a tree will be six I really get a really
nice position give me the chance for us
yes an 86
who wants to repeat this line alright
well this one twice right I'd repeat it
there's a b3 now he's changing okay how
about for example night before there we
should be one and A five
sure Castle Bishop ace I know this no
Bishop 86 Queen B - it's the pawn is
hanging it's giving me pretty big dot
pawn for free absolutely no strings
attached
whoa it's giving me that pawn for free
so I think I'm just going to take it
there we go come on
there we go that's it jameelah I love
taking points after shot castle my idea
is probably to go Queen c3 and then
Queen 85 and I can scape at least I got
that I also bring my knight to be for
night before he wants to go probably to
beat 9 they should be working for me
come on they should be working night
before and after B should be too I can
always go Queen c2 aiming to exchange
some pieces and I should be happy with
that end game not so sure though so
night before
oh so much stress you know yes good
stuff I'd be happy one
okay I was curious how what would happen
in this battle it's very very serious
battle so Queen C 3 route B 3 just Queen
C 6 for example nothing happens so
you're gonna go for this
Quincy 3 thing is got to play rook b3
and then Quincy 6 only move but then the
a 4 point is hanging so some troubles
over there also for him
looks like he's got a lot of active
active pieces but at some point if I
consolidate my position should be ok
what does it take to get out that for
checkmate or for some for example you
know that's like to celebrate a cold
yeah just but never tank I mean and I'm
not winning any game here what you wanna
hear you know find some brilliant see
her let's go
well I'm warming up you know I'm talking
nonsense all around you you have really
good stuff while talking yourself and
see the match is still young we're not
even halfway does force like match is
still young stairs like 290 more games
or something yeah then Queen c6 all him
off and then give me my pawn it's
Totalus I think we figured out the
secret this guy hangs almost poncey just
taking yeah give me that plot oh really
okay so this allow me to to take the
bishop person going for that for sure
and now 94 28 is also interesting 94 6x
Roxy 3 okay Knight e4 Knight e5 rook c2
could be a move okay
I'm going for this yes
but then [ __ ] see one it's pretty
interesting
- all right life is tough 94 Luke sit
one Queenie eight I want all my pieces
in the background 95 but now Quincy -
what's up what happens eyes got just
Knight takes e4 because the rukon ds3 is
protected so alright nothing happens so
let's go queenie 8 here Knight takes e4
detective for Roxy three and then my
plan was to go maybe something like f6
but then Knight c4 is pretty strong it
goes through b3 hmm and the viewers
can't see up on your screen keeps going
dark and light yeah there's a lot of
distractions here that the people aren't
even aware of doesn't seem to fit
mystery will okay f6 Knight c4 and then
he wants to jump here to b6 looks pretty
annoying
alright b5 come on
find something baby find something
not easy running out of time
how about a five-year a five so my idea
is just to go Bishop b4 there to block
the B file and then maybe route k-6
something like that I only got 40
seconds this London system is really
killing me
I got to do something before looks good
let's see what he does now I want to
develop my bishop finally again the same
problem over and over in the in every
game this Bishop from CA I want to go
Bishop d7 but then maybe he's got rooks
he's seven in this position but I could
go maybe we should be six okay he goes
94 now Luke a6 covering the d6 square
and also aiming to to go now Bishop d7
so there's no Knight b6 attacking my
rook and also at the same time
protecting a four so come on if I
managed to get out this Bishop I would
be in a nice situation come on I just
need one more move Erik be a nice guy
okay when you come to Spain I'll treat
you very well you know Luke be to just
Bishop d7 right then they pollinate on a
floor is hanging what does he want to do
he wants to go to a - okay he gives me
that point for free so I'll take it
Bishop takes a four now the bishop is
coming to c6 okay didn't see that coming
okay Bishop c6 nothing happens now when
I go up to d5 with my bishop and put
some pressure
hopefully queen g4 now probably f6 looks
like good move so there's no 95 or
Bishop e5 now I want to bring this
Bishop to d5 put pressure on the c4
Knight then maybe also Queen d7
oh I didn't see that 96 what's his idea
after Queen d7 okay I just play Queen d7
probably he's got to go back and after
Knight c4 that could be Bishop d5 there
and then Brooke see a disco me
so probably in I'm in a good shape there
okay let's play Bishop d5 or rook c8
looks good rook c8 looks good looks good
so now this night hasn't got a room 92
I could play Luke a8 now so I gotta be
careful with my time so let's say Bishop
b5 rook takes rook takes and at some
point I have Bishop a three-fer before
oh my god say bishop c6 they're
controlling everything now when I start
running with this point so for example
let's say Bishop f8 a4 a3 and nothing
happens come on let's go let's go let's
go let's go my friends IIITs coming
IIITs coming g6 there's nothing there a3
now Bishop d5 a 2 that should be the
move Bishop d5 a - lets go let's go
let's go let's go let's play f5 so
there's no e 4th there in that position
now let's play a - a - a - a - a - e for
take stakes think I can take everything
and then Queen takes oh my god just
blunder everything so stupid Queen d5 oh
my god that was a terrible move God rook
d7 still I got some I got no advantage
now keen f7 let's say
my god what was that move okay here Ruki
seven Ruki eight rookie seven got
nothing better in this position yes got
so much advantage just alright
Game three yeah yeah so we played like
free games three plus two right that was
the third yeah third three to four we're
just we're waiting to the end that's
what are you chicken in it okay making
it an exciting yeah I mean don't have to
you can just crush this guy but I guess
we'll make it exciting yeah sure
four three all right come on the London
system can't just keep getting points
office of course should bring with them
and we gotta beat the London like one
but I just played with the black pieces
right yeah yeah we just faced the world
of it so I should get white now come on
guys what should I play now I'm thinking
about playing people ready to Kings
Indian Kings Indian this is your white
though yeah yes before now let's see
what happens should I play the Lana sis
again the London citizen guide no way no
way okay
Knight c3 let's see what he plays on d5
all right Knight a three now three to
four in Ihram Bishop e7 I'm gonna go for
it Bishop g5 this this line alright and
a six ok cool now that's what Magnus
does that's cool alright so I'm gonna
take on the five and then play something
like Bishop d3 or for example or even
Bishop e2 it looks good
you should be three let's say B should
be three and try to play these kind of
positions pretty boring that's my style
guys don't expect anything I don't
expect any fireworks you know
while I'm playing so for example Quincy
- yeah and I can't see anything on the
scoreboard but it's mostly for me it's
mostly for my benefit are not would be
great to start over there the red just
doesn't show up on the street
minority attack let's say uh he wants to
go 96 and and escape this this Bishop
from there so hmm
all right all right okay life is hard
yeah so group b1 it's 96 96 97 yeah
alright 9686 could be applied but then
this night on g6 Canyon so I'm gonna go
be four straightaway here and then he
can't play really eight-six because I
just take on f6 and here I'm gonna go a
4
this is what everybody does here yeah
trying to create some pressure with now
I see his plan yeah he wants to go
eight-six there yeah you guys can check
out what can I do yeah it takes it takes
a tix and now Bishop g6 could be
interesting takes all right give me that
hmm
gonna take that too now for example
route b6 looks interesting the list rook
basics could be a move but then Bishop
g4
alright let's write Brooke besiege the
thing is after Bishop C seven days
Knight takes d5 very beautiful there
because of the CTX Queen takes you seven
it's a long way from over it's a long
way from over yeah still like three
hours so now what should I say here
maybe 93 we need for just g3 nothing
happens I'm a bit scared about this
attack here jacket that's alright can I
go now Knight takes d5 we should take
sage to Kinte taste food we made for
King D 1 seat XE 5 looks good night xe5
give me that there it is
let's see if it works please work so we
should take skin takes removed Sundays I
calculated everything Queen h4 kinky 165
and then I think there is Bishop g6
there this Bishop g6 Ponte extend Queen
takes c6 and then I would be threatened
to go group b7 should be good but you
know I blunder so many times in my life
like I don't trust in myself anymore
no no no I gotta get it get it back here
I get your confidence back so Queen h4
only move there I guess or queen day 6 -
Queen they suggest Knight f4 so that's
why and now he's got to take there and I
think there's Bishop takes g6 looks good
and now I'm gonna take with my queen I'm
gonna take with my queen here
and see what happens looks good looks
good looks good and then this rook b7
coming so yeah three to four New York's
favor yeah but not after this game we're
looking to make it four to four Ruki
seven all right hey Brooke c6 roca fate
probably after g3 it's got to go to a
tree but then nothing that's a little
bit scary so f3 where's the took this
bishop going f3 f3 looks good yeah I got
for this go away simple guy Brooke me
one yeah then Brooke afraid was there
was some pressure on f2 there was some
pressure enough to so Bishop g5 Bishop
h5 sorry not probably Queen D 626 so he
can take on e3 because there is Queen d5
and then I also threatened to go rook b8
exchanging some pieces
so probably Bishop f7 and then I could
try to go g3 even g3 but then Queen h3
and I don't like the position so so
there's it could be a drone all right
let's go rook b8 takes takes and then
Queen b3 in order to protect my III
point or even Eve for looks good even if
for looks good but Queen b3 I like this
move so the structure is pretty well is
pretty good so I'm gonna go Queen d3 I'm
probably for later can also try to
improve the position of mine of my my
queen queen d3 Bishop d6 Queen e2 and
then rookie want something like this
aiming to go for some efore okay Queen
g5 let's say rook e1 here now bishop g6
let's say Knight f1 protecting
everything here and alright some point I
should be able to to start a pawn march
there okay it goes pretty interesting
move gonna go Queen B 2 8 4 I'm probably
just I don't know what's going on here
yeah well Pepe has good experience with
ball games that's really gonna be the
key to this much I don't know what I'm
supposed to do here
ruk ruk c2 rookie - and then rook c1 I
could play e4 here let's go efore take
stakes and then less I should better run
with these pawns and getting out of time
actually so and as I'm also threatening
Queen III in this position so exchanging
everything in that could be an idea that
could be an idea queen III so his first
to take I should take back with my room
with my route
maybe rook d1 it's a really interesting
move but then maybe even group d2 could
work in that position route d2 or even
group II one exchange and everything now
Queenie Trinity is very good Queen III I
think it's very good let's go Queen III
Queen takes rook takes and then run run
run run run
rap we said these passers one of them is
kind of like make it this time
yeah I hope so I love so man's time
come on come on do it d5 let's go oh
this is just crazy where I just did yeah
this is just crazy this is just
ridiculous yeah what's going on here
they just never win the race this is
just ridiculous okay
I can't even lose now this okay I can't
even lose this now so I better be
careful so let's say night it's 2:00 to
4:00 to play Knight f3 here I mean all
right let's play another three here he's
gonna take it
yeah Kim takes on King g4 yeah this is
gonna end in a draw probably oh yeah mm
again okay drawn upset good feels good
all the time but he's a good fighter to
him so we got four more games right four
and a half that's game for ya oh you
guys can't read this that says three and
a half to four now Eric's favorite all
right four more games and then ten games
- one minute sir
yeah before okay
he changes oh this is where the match
really turns or Knight c3 okay I'm gonna
go Knight f6 this is a three all right
yeah that's move I know
a tree okay
let me think a little bit so I'm gonna
go g6 here why not
g6 going for the fee on keto 95 Wow he
knows what he's doing
give me that yeah he plays all these
he's tricky I don't know if you wanna
call him nonsense or what everybody
plays he's like tricky things on a
stream all the time you okay
and you know I mean normally he's
playing just whatever pets Thursday's
joking around he's playing okay just
crushes people so let's hope that's not
us just getting crushed by some
hopefully this is just losing for him
and we figure it out that's it looks
very interesting
all right below some places yeah just
give the piece back beat takes Bishop c4
and gonna go for sure Castle here and
short cuts off all right so difficult my
piece is maybe we should be six even you
should be six looks interesting the
place so I'm gonna go for this takes
takes and then Queen d7 protect connect
my rooks probably some v5 later and
hopefully we get a nice position
yeah I never would have give a little
the night back so many squares yeah
sorry if I was coming but I took your
night and I'm not giving it for now I
would love to go be five at some point I
don't know if or d5 that was the move I
was concerned about but here I think I
can just play ninety five ninety five
and then I think I have a nice Center
nice bone Center so context yeah I think
this one went far for us went well for
us but you know everything and then I
get a phone for free and then I just run
through everything and they just draw
you know I just plugged in my pointing
one move so so I'm gonna take here look
at those points they look so beautiful
medic now I was thinking about taking
with my pump but then see for now that's
I don't believe win takes is also very
interesting Queen takes should be very
interesting to so I'm gonna take with my
queen and then I should
be a little bit better nothing special
Halloween all right let's play c5 and
then bring the rook to e8 and then
probably I don't know if start pushing
let's say e 5 or even see 45s D for
something like this but still nothing
special yeah nothing special for us it's
10 seconds up in the clock so now this
is called the Halloween can be done or
something somebody's right in there I do
this yeah without a a 3 in g6 if they
just take right away with your knight on
e5
it's Halloween get it all right I did a
video on it real in costume yeah yeah
wear costume okay yeah good luck you
should definitely take Jonathon besoms
advice go Pepe ignore Jonathon
concentrate for good luck
I think it's the match goes on I'll
probably start talking about yes okay
now if we could be interesting if he
allows that so in order to play d4
because okay I can always push this a
pawn but then sometimes he can block the
pass pawn and then I could have some
witnesses on the white squares before
very interesting so takes takes d4
that's my idea or even d4 straight away
the first straightaway looks very
interesting so gonna go for this
d4 okay pawn takes Queen takes pawn
takes pawn takes yeah I should
centralize my Queen on d5 he didn't let
me do that so I have to go there group 2
c1 I'm probably now Queen b6 is a very
interesting move Queen b6 because now
he's got to take and then he's got to
remove the bishop and then we'll get the
pawn on a three so Queen b6 Queen takes
pawn checks and then has got to go let's
say to g5 and then rook takes a three so
I think we are again better but it's
this kind of position that it's not easy
to play a role so oh my god he's seven
no he is not even blonde or anything
because there's Bishop east
seven there so all right
he managed to save the pawn for now for
now
Ruka five he's got to go to e7 and then
probably I could push this guy here so
let's say d3 you explain natural
I'm gonna go root D 5 and then yeah root
day 1 Brooke d5 or yeah
look the fight looks good and then there
I have some Bishop b2 ideas also in mind
should do something with this game too
Bishop b4 and then probably can I do
here route d8 looks natural or even
Bishop b2 rook b8 looks natural
so let's go for this route b8 r OT 8 and
rook c7 same idea
activating his route but all right
nothing really bad happens there how
about Bishop t4 now we should be for
root D - I think it's his idea
so go for Ruby 5 here probably be 5 and
then try to to bring Mike in only 40
seconds should hurry up come on baby
it's too big guy let's let's say King g8
and then probably group these 17 f7 this
kind of moves
rook d7 boss may be a better option
there bishop c3 and now a guess takes
takes everything there so let's say
Bishop f8 each of f8 targeting the age
well done our wife's gonna start
watching it all right
make a good impression okay okay I'll
try to do that it's taking this one so
b5 now it's going Bishop back to before
probably or route B 3 can I go d2 here
we're gonna go D to hear me - I'm gonna
go D - here let's see what happens so I
can always protect this point by playing
Bishop h6 and then I got some Bishop
group d3 ideas only 20 seconds in my
clock I can get easily crazy in these
positions I know myself so I'm gonna
play Bishop 8 6 here so protecting this
guy and their son Roxy Roxy a truck c1
ideas in this position so he can't ride
route B - there exactly but then I'll
bring my kin to the action
let's bring the key into the action kini
- probably is gonna save the day for him
he need to recreate it's got to go back
and then I don't know if I can improve
in that position Roxy - let's say rook
d7 so there's there's no check on c7 g3
now gonna play rook to e3 so to stop f4
in that position which was very very
interesting and now maybe I can play
Bishop f8 and then try to probably it's
just draw yeah probably just a drop
takes takes and the pollen III is
hanging so give me that give me that
rook d4 probably Keaney probably is just
a troll yeah but okay probably this is
just wrong
all right oh my god rugby three so I
better start doing something
rugby three it's got to take there yeah
let's take dark and then root before
yeah oh my god
Roxy 4v4 and this should be a draw but I
don't trust in myself lo h5 let's say in
f8 you got this here yeah I cannot do
anything here so give a check there and
look B to G for could be an IV let's see
hmm
takes and v3 oh my god check
here I just blundered upon qh7
just losing this is just so ridiculous
it's 1887 this is just terrible yeah
it's just so ridiculous
Dean eight-six rubgy for Wow let's play
this move maybe I can still save it
rookie sixteen eight five can gonna go
teenage five here rook g5 King takes and
I think I save it okay alright
rookie for three throws in a row yeah I
mean I was putting pressure was nothing
special but okay I almost managed to
lose this game ridiculous
alright I need a win now come on
little wave it like this since you guys
can't really read it anyway three to
Section three more of these so we move
on to one minute and now I'm gonna be
good on drinks and stuff you want water
you're fine okay so three more games and
then the craziness starts yeah so okay
efore what we just before no less game
wasn't in London so I got confused
and now before he played the time on of
right so time I know what's playing
gonna play Knight c3 here so Knight c3
it goes for is six alright then I'll
play Knight of three he goes d5 I can
hear I will play Bishop b5 so I don't
want to enter in the main lines of the
time man off looks like he knows what
he's doing I'm gonna play Bishop d3 here
so now sometimes you wanna take on the
floor and then play 92 and then C 3 so
here sure Castle is the main line a
knight c6 alright now I'm gonna play b3
I know about this game about this line
sorry I actually played again with the
white pieces like that like many many
years ago I think I should go here
Bishop b2 and maybe he wants to go d5 in
this position Queen c7 and now I think
Bishop e2 is really interesting here
just to go D for D for and then this is
well placed on b2 so Knight takes d4
Knight d4 again sorry let's see that
seems maybe even rook e1 okay he's got C
gets a bishop pair but I mean I live in
in development right so after Knight
takes e to Quinn take c2 then I want to
bring the rook to d1 finally play d4 and
all right I'm gonna go Bishop f1 now so
now I'm threatened to take actually in
d4 but he won't Bishop db7
and I'm gonna go d3 protecting my pawn
on d4 so now I'm really threatening
finally to take on the four I guess just
then I got 92 but I think he's got some
Bishop b4 which is very annoying so not
so sure all right rooks see a pressure
on the c2 pawn how about if I just go g3
here
let's go g3 so I want to go Bishop g2
and reallocate this guy here from f1
which is doing basically nothing yeah I
know eric is very resilient as you
safe it's pretty tough to play against
him
sure castle and then finally go away 92
Knight takes Queen takes prolly is going
to take on f3 rather than on e 2 because
that improves my peace is co Zealand
thanks for watching
alright so night exit 3
Bishop takes a 3 and d5 probably is the
move here and can I go a 5 year he 597
Knight f4 was my intention I think so so
I'm gonna go for this be 5 97 9 f4 and
then yeah I got some tricks on the
queenside sorry on the key inside I
could try to go something like Bishop g2
Queen g4 something like that and then
some tricks on a6 my ghosty for he cuts
my bishop and all right I could take on
b7 then Queen to g4 and what's going on
there so takes takes also c3 would be
interesting there c3 but then root da
takes takes I don't like my position
actually so Bishop takes Queen takes and
now what should i do there yeah let's
take that guy and for example just
Queenie to Queen e2 protecting a 5 so
there are no Queen c7 and Knight takes
e5 moves and here what to do maybe h4 h5
stuff like that start putting some
pressure on the key inside I don't know
rook d8 maybe a 4 is an interesting move
here a 4 a 4
I don't know what's going on Jonathan
it's again a tough position here
yeah looks like kind of equal so at this
I can try to open the a file then get
good gets an activity for my rook but
also I'm hoping he goes for b4 and then
I don't have to worry about the Queen
side anymore but probably oh he went for
this
I'm happy and happy so queen g4 Queen c7
and then Knight takes pawn takes and
then kina fate nothing happens so
mm-hmm let's go h4 here looks natural
probably even Queenie for this end game
should be nice then I can double rooks
on the e-file to protect my fo e v on
sorry but also trying to attack looks
looks looks interesting so neither fate
okay you can join us tonight a fake you
can also watch the stream different
Queen to g4 and now when a double rooks
on the e-file and finally bring this guy
back to life the bishop on b2 is doing
basically nothing now again we got some
pressure here going on rook e1 bishop c1
there are some threats on 86 you could
try to go night 87 though London 95 I
should be aware of that too so nine
eight seven million night at three so
prophylaxis even my Bishop Queen b6 I
don't understand that move but I'm just
gonna go Bishop c1 and then try to
Bishop g5 now I see his idea I see his
idea all right
life is tough so when the chatter rosin
fence put this Bobby yeah yeah surely
the real ones sherry can I bring a
Knight to c4 that would be really nice
bringing a Knight to c4 that would be my
dream so for example rook e1 and then
that's nice f4 not f2 is 84
it looks really good well go through the
at the front desk go through that door
right all right so rooky one we got a
nice position guys here so I'm gonna go
f4 here trying to create some sort of
attack there 9f 294 92 94 actually after
92 we a 330 matter of 6 so he should be
really careful now
all right 96
let's go 96 still I don't see how I'm
gonna make progress but ok neck c4 I'm
gonna put this nail here
yeah f5 is gonna be play at some point
but at first I want to improve my pieces
a little bit so route d7 I'm gonna go
Queen f3 now making use of this I are
gonna maybe the Queen on e4 is very well
placed Queenie for then King G 2 then
maybe even the keen on h3 so kingi - um
maybe Kim a tree g4 ah he managed to get
to get that move hmm I should have
played a5 of course you can play 95 here
95 i define a 9 worse so I cannot allow
that so I'm gonna play d4 maybe I'm
risking too much I don't know come on
root G to root G 1 and G 5 that's it
that's idea here g5 here come on G Phi
Pepe hmm all right Queen b7 gotta go g5
takes takes and we can still put some
pressure in this game game I keep doing
something with my feet that yes it's
ruining the the scream it must be the
power chord takes takes give me 7 root G
1 where the stream keeps going like
darker and lighter but it's probably
because like we're charging it and then
I'm charging it somewhere down there the
support that I must keep getting pressed
Keeney for this is one more distraction
here is it impossible to make any
progress here
sawed off I'm gonna go f5 here you know
I keep trying but he's he's fighting all
the time this guy
okay now I should be careful with f6 so
I know how this ends you know yeah I
know how these ends so I'm gonna go
Ruchi to here maybe g6 can play g6 here
I don't know complete g6 here kingi
scheme eight-six gonna go route g5 here
he's forced to go back to g8 I guess and
then maybe and just maybe I could try to
go okay I'm gonna buy some Tempe here
let's say Ruka 5 makes a rookie 5 f6 Wow
I'm gonna take here and then I'm gonna
play Brooke to g6
it's got no checks it's got no checks so
I'm gonna go route g2 here to protect
the seventh rank and then I'm
threatening to take the pawn on f6 right
so here he's threatening to give some
checks
so I'm gonna protect the F file and I
threatened to take the f1 so let's see
what happens here let's see what happens
give me that give me that
and then gonna play rook f5 here Ruka v
is forced to take k king g5 and now got
like hundreds of checks if I want where
are you going so I'm gonna go King f6
I'm probably keen f7 it's got 2 seconds
this was - yeah
bout time something went our way okay I
put a lot of pressure in this game but
then he was fighting so much you know he
has to break at some point man that's
what I mean that's it there we go
all right excellent this is 3 plus 2
right I mean I challenged him three plus
two yeah so yeah yeah good game all
right all right have six again the
London season now I'm gonna change I'm
gonna play there the kinks in there okay
ghost Knight c3 d5 III this system
Bishop g7 h4 Wow Wow h4 okay let's just
stop that joke all tied up that's right
and now yeah let's go shark Castle here
and then try to go see five in the next
move let me go check his face see if
he's crying he never really changes
that's the problem he's such a rational
he's always alright oh he wants to go g4
at some point okay let's just try to
break in the center see if I will have
to do something I don't want to get
crushed on the keen side while doing
nothing so D takes e5 and now when a
five could be interesting yeah I'm gonna
go Queen a five one of the ideas could
be 94 in the next move actually and also
yeah Queen takes e5 looks reasonable do
so five five five
all right ninety-four is my threat guys
here so let's see if also that Queen
takes Queen D for 24 looks strange
knight c6 what's current 96 takes takes
before Queen a3 I like that he wants to
go maybe maybe Bishop e5 in that
position but I think okay
Knight 97 it's also very interesting
here 97 97 Wow
I like this move Knight f2 d7 and then
I'm threatening to take on e5 a knight
c6 before anything I can just go
Queen a3 this is so complicated guys I
don't see anything can gonna go for this
we take c5 we take it five yeah yeah
what do I do maybe I can just resign
their Queen takes e5 e6 we takes d5 come
on prepare em here here there we take c5
there should be something there there
should be something Knight takes e5
Bishop takes then I was thinking about
rook ta their queen efore and maybe
there's just nothing right maybe just
blundered so e 6 is the other option
there is six Queenie four and then
Knight takes e5 before he goes for that
and then ah maybe Queen d8 is very
interesting here so queen eight three
ninety five I missed that I miss that so
Queen d8 should I go Queen d8 here
let's go Quinn DF I don't know what's
going on this is extremely tough because
now he can't take on on d5 with the
Queen because there's ninety five and
then we win a piece so actually the
threat is quite strong we are threatened
in 95 and 96 probably he can go
something like Bishop b5 there but then
even playing position is something like
a 5 could be interesting there so a 5 he
can never play a 3 because 8x before
position is extremely complicated guys I
don't get anything but right
even after Bishop e5 Queen c7 looks
interesting there's so many things going
on here so there should be 5 a 5 could
be remove there or a 6 Bishop a4
something like b5 there could be good
could be working I have no idea no idea
a 5 also looks very very interesting so
let's see let's see
a 5 what do you do against a 5
Queen takes Queen takes you can avert
the Queen take so I'm gonna go a
five-year and then poof a five now I'm
threatened to go a takes before but he
can take on d5 with with the night that
was a terrible move that was a terrible
move he six yeah that was really stupid
okay it still we got something here
it takes me for 46 seconds 46 seconds so
Queen a five could be the next move here
but then there's 97 all right all right
all right
I'm gonna go see six so it's got to take
on before and then there could be some
not Queen a five move again I don't know
what's going to also Queen takes age
four Knights a move it's so complicated
this game
that was good yeah that was good so let
me think about this
hmm give me that Queen takes and then
rookie fight what's going on here okay
five crazy crazy stuff
no route k5 Lee takes rook takes and
then the ruckus he's got to protect the
e5 Knight I felt like there had
something before for sure but somehow I
just created all the answer twin takes
before Queen takes me six no not that is
he c4
how about if I just take that give me
that uh he wants to go a four there yeah
exactly that was clever that was really
clever come on I'm gonna go 96 oh that
was a terrible move Wintec c3 but thanks
Queen b6 eight seconds I have no time 96
was just a terrible move 96 was just a
terrible mode give me that give me that
now I'm forced to take here and then
Knight c5 got this c3 pawn still have
some hopes got some hops with that pawn
so I'm gonna go rook e8 they're kind of
go somewhere else
93 followed by c2 could be could be
interesting oh my god oh my god 96 still
still fighting still fighting still
fighting in this position we want to go
see to who does Eric have helping him we
both have extra people openness so 16
seconds
come on blunder something Eric Bishop d7
give me that 93 come on I want to go see
two in this position I want to go see
two in this position so let's see
Ruki eight here see - it's a next move
so I'm gonna take that and just loosen
see - yes
and just losing here takes takes and I
can just resign da that's all right
who's Eric half helping him come on
yeah I'm really helping over here six
five
all right I need to win this and then do
we get to the craziness like yeah all
right so hmm what should I play here I'm
gonna go for again one last game one
last game c5 gonna go 93 93 is 6 and now
93 again same variation here it should
be free and all right let's go sure
castle or yeah sure Castle do you change
your opening repertoire when you play
bullet I don't know I never played
laughing like 10 games in ya role like
you should be too can I go a 5 here 5
then 94 but then ob5 looks good 94 takes
takes ok gonna go if 5 yeah let's go b5
so Knight takes he took we take C - I
like that position got a lot of pieces
out so Knight takes Knight g4 Knight
takes d4 she takes Bishop takes D taxi
3d take c3 and I think what's a pawn up
so let's see ya never really talk
anymore they stop talking they're still
all watching always talk Network London
is the hardest repertoire practically an
expert yeah for sure
London's been giving us trouble alright
and then d4 that's a DF
think we got a nice position he can't
play these six and then we're aiming
maybe even to play okay Bishop g5 now
looks looks interesting Bishop g5 it's
got to go Queen c7 I guess all our
pieces are out that's good news
let's go you should g5 Bishop e7 them
all right maybe even four let me think
okay let's take that and then route d1
and we are threatened Indy takes e5
followed by root D fire so probably it's
got to go we should be seven but now
what should we play here
so let's say rookie one prolly is going
to go short castle here in this position
and now for example Queen III I like by
night this mission is not very good so
we have to make sure that we don't open
this diagonal for this bishop so for
example something like detects if I will
be a terrible position on mistake but
then okay he wants to take there but I
think that's not problematic at all
because we just take with our night so
I'm gonna stick with my plan
so maybe even eight 4 H 3 yeah let's
play Queen a4 here so now f6 I think
we'll reach an angle where White's
better so it takes Queen takes rook
takes and then this rookie 7 for example
when I gave some pressure to Mike in
let's say a three we need six all right
I'm gonna go a tree so C takes e4 it's
not an option anymore Knight takes d4
comes with the tempo and a5
alright a fight trying to create some
some counter play over there but I just
keep I'll keep just playing here
rook III could be thinking about some
Knight g5 moves now a4 can I just grab
that I won't do that I won't do that so
for example Knight g5 26 he's going to
go in through route did you hear so
protecting C - I don't want any
surprises here and a plan could be now
95 followed by Rupe g3 for example it
takes a takes and now my king is going
to 2h - nothing happens yeah rook a1 and
can I go something like yeah I go Knight
g5 here and then rook g3 he comes to -
to g6 I could be threatened in 94 for
example in that position and then Knight
of 6 so let's see Queen eight six that
was a good move
that was a good move so windy for looks
good too windy for looks good
right yes
when g-force and I can retreat my night
without any problem I'm most of
threatening the d7 pawn will see Bishop
C is six could be a move here but then
maybe I can start improving the position
of my pieces for example rook at three
still I don't like that this queen is
just looking to these two rooks yeah
exactly
so for example Bishop c6 and now it's
not clear what to do so for example even
f4 could be a move here
f4 yeah I'm gonna play f4 so now this
queen is not looking to destroy two
rooks and after f6 I could think about
just taking on f6 Queen takes f6 and
then for example yeah that looks good
for him
so f6f-5 ff6 and then maybe I know he
goes through if that moves can I go at
five years I don't think so
he just wants to double rock there and
then put me in some trouble so I'll
think I don't think I'll think
all right
I'm going not a three here so then my
plan is not h4 and not f5 because
there's no Queen g6 but there's a [ __ ]
e7 so it's got to be really careful
about that and going I see now there's
no please look at four so I'm gonna go
rupee one so I remove one of these rooks
now there are no background problems and
then I come back to my initial plan yeah
exactly
so I'm gonna take this or even f5 looks
pretty good
five let me think f5 and then Knight f3
okay let's go ahead five here that five
win takes eight takes and then the
knight comes to f3 I think we got a
better end game here we need six just
Knight f3 and then we got keep pushing
like say f6 in that position
okay you played there and then d5 what's
going on here this is gonna be crazy
again this is going to be crazy
he's putting pressure spring the king or
t6 or what should I play yeah King g3
spring the king Oh rook d5 but then he
six I don't know what's going on there
is six let's see we play the first like
we know them
yeah these six could be an option he
takes with the D pawn he's not going to
take with the depo but then I could
force that I could actually F takes have
takes D takes d6 route group there okay
he doesn't go for this so what should I
play here
d6 I think he can't take everything
because there is d7 coming so now I'm
threatened to go eat seven and put this
pot over there which looks really nice
for me so he can't really take and then
I'm gonna play this is seven move and
the king is gonna be on eh so stuck
there I guess I have a lot of moves good
move from that position my team is also
coming to the center that's always good
news should be women I guess no take
stakes now hear this you have to commit
there's rook F 2 coming okay No
I can't do that okay I'm gonna go Keane
F for now Keaney fives coming let's go
c3 c3 is coming to stop everything okay
I should go see three I guess and then
9c - I just need to reach c7 yeah I just
need to reach c7 and I will be winning I
think this could be weighing in there
come on come on come on
94 is the move now or even night before
before I don't know three seconds it's
got three seconds so I'm just gonna play
94 come on guys 95 and 97 okay 95 gotta
be really careful 97 now I'm taking
fresh de-spawn and be 5 and then I'm
going back to Seattle c7 there's no
counter play there and then we just win
this game okay Queen give me that here
there Tina 5 give me that give me that
that's it
all right 9:00 to 5:00
okay we managed to win here so difficult
yeah this chest yeah good we're out of
this segment
yeah all right man six all right and
then this is gonna be crazy yeah I saw
him plain like very very fast
yeah been prepping for this match this
match was kind of last second though
probably did you guys decide on this
link yesterday I don't know I guess from
Daniel yeah okay ten games yeah and
let's go game number one this is it six
to six
let's see how my mouse is working today
nothing else matters this is it laughing
else mutters not afraid let's see what
did we place so I'm gonna go g3 pre move
yeah G to Castle B for C fairness Quincy
to b5 all right give me that
here here
well it's my turn oh my god
92 wanna take that guy 93 94 go away B 3
B 3 C fibers coming probably ok a 3e 593
attacking this guy it's got to do
something the bishop when I shake is
hanging the bishop on a sec is hanging
so 95 ok Queen g5 it's got to protect
that Eve for probably it's coming before
go away Knight text before quint XE 3
then 9300 B should be three nothing
happens
give me that give me that give me that
guy if I it's gonna come here eat 5 give
me that no the knight is hanging on
before the night is hanging on before
that's it that's it all right
we should have want could be the move
for Bishop before attacking this guy
there give me that give me that Bishop
g2 root K 1 rook t1 east root D one
rookie 3 that's a move I'm gonna take
that gonna take that that's for me
that's for me root D 8 here's the
segment all right really favors us here
ok I should be able to check made this
in 15 second time we're heading so bad 7
6 this match just started alright so I'm
gonna go d6 the Philidor yes mr. Grand
Master you're the most exciting
excitable entertaining person I've never
narrate your own play you sound like
Maurice is narrating again
b5 give me that poem before I'm gonna
take that I'm gonna take that I'm gonna
take that pawn on e4 that's for me
that's for me that's for me Queen c7
protecting everything take that and root
d8 for example I don't like this
position actually so I'm gonna kill
night
seven am I taking this guy from before
am I taking this guy from before I am I
am
we should be six all right so nice if I
should give me that you should be six
you should be 6f6 protecting everything
we should be seven I'm gonna trade
everything possible here here give me
that
eight takes before you create the key
eight Bishop takes group the eight when
I exchange everything this is for me
here why the eration for meeting and I
am come on you're not give some fresh
hair to my kin no more checks you should
see for there give me that oh my god
I don't believe this okay this queen e7
no problem we need seven and then Bishop
d3 d4 okay gonna take that oh my god
here give me the Queen give me the Queen
that's for me that's for me alright
takes takes that's checkmate
alright eight two six eight two six all
right I'm gonna go let's go then no okay
gonna take that can I take that on
purpose
I don't know yes yes yes yes London
tonight my plane like terrible both okay
gonna bring this Knight to e4 then
develop my pieces we should be three
route d1 something like that then the
other rook to e1 nothing happens here
Knight comes to c5 attacking the b7 pawn
f4 f4 is coming f4 is coming come on
come on come on here then Knight takes
Knight c4 when I grab that when I grab
that night c5 rook takes c3 I just
blended that roof takes c3 okay they
didn't see that that's good
then he wants to exchange everything we
got the bishop / we got a better
position but the structure is just
terrible for us so king d3 but I start
moving my pawns here on the Queen side
let's go he blundered upon so I'm gonna
take that I'm gonna take the other one
oh here controlling everything
controlling everything check bishop d4
remove a five okay give me that c4 a
five it's coming it's coming here then
King takes King goes in there Kinji six
here he can't take you can't really take
f4 then f5 check check check
I should be I should be hurry up so Tina
for your earring give me that in flight
mode be sure before give me four
Oh draw draw draw draw all right all
right this is damn crazy yeah all right
so three games yeah seven more only
seven more get it back together let's go
okay I'm gonna go for the fill it over
again and I go for the fill either all
right okay we started continuum okay I'm
gonna go I'm gonna stay there so II five
the Queen come three seven Queen comes
three 727s rook g8 nothing happens here
just develop my pieces 94 could be
interesting I'm gonna play rook g8 so so
yes I'm gonna close the position with c5
a6 could be interesting now rook b8 I
want to go b5 here takes takes takes
takes and then Queen b7 could be the
move here attack in there so route
before it's coming attacking me for now
I want to go a five a four that's a DRA
four come on come on come on KYNA faith
King g7 looks interesting so I'm gonna
go there and gonna try to bring all my
heavy pieces so 85 Bishop d7 nine
bringing this rook to b8 for example
could be extremely interesting for us
come on come on Tina fate there oh my
god Tina fate kini 7 Keaney 8 he takes
everything there
Wow I'm running away I don't want any
problems there so I'm gonna take him b3
and then gonna go route k-8 and Queen a7
and then try to give checkmate that's
checkmate in two moves I guess there so
check check check check check check
ruk a3 I don't know what's going on
Queen a1 check bouquet - give me that
give me that give me that rook b8
so there's queen bee too windy for
nothing happens Ruka a bouquet for takes
takes
create Luke h8 take take so give me that
give me that give me that
kimby six here I'm gonna take that check
check check check check check check
check detector tick tick tick tick
somebody's saying paper slowly giving up
a year of his cardiac life or a win here
all right I'm gonna go for the English
opening now six more six more yes so
we're gonna play he's trying to f5 it's
going for the Dutch doctor opening okay
c5 that b3 and gonna put double
fianchetto here Queen takes a problem so
queen d3 root B 1 let's say takes takes
e4 taking everything here f4 Wow 92 92
give me that gonna play g4 go away f3
tricky takes takes Keaton comes to h1
nothing happens rook Jiwon rook G to
bring the other rook
I bring the other rook so taking here
Queenie 3 let's see what happens so for
example f4 I think it's possible here
this rook g6 so I'm gonna go f5 here now
route g6 the threat Luke g6 the threat
so I'm gonna take everything here takes
takes takes now he can't really take a
guess ace Queen g3 and then we're
exchanging every piece and the pond from
h8 from h2 runs a lot here this guy runs
a lot gonna go 8-4 here kina 3 and then
we start running with h5 we're
completely winning this game the same
game
d5 check check check check check check
in it for but I take everything I'm
gonna take everything nothing happens
here
8 7 h8 Queen h1 we run and that's it
a trick yeah give me that got a pond no
no still nice he's got one he's got a
pun there's no still yes okay checkmate
I was about to take the 8 point that was
the drawing now ten and a half six and a
half huh how many more is yeah right by
former five games to go yeah yeah we
just replaying five no matter what
probably yeah okay do you have a bush we
can run up the score
we got a right where we want him what's
about to take the pawn that was a drag
queen a six was tell me yeah so is here
that's all I'm good for today this 40 of
us comments and I challenging again yeah
let's go look at him like I'll get a
minute yes I challenge me again yeah all
right so let's go gonna play now the
French if he goes for Eve or gonna play
the French native 3e 5 this line is very
interesting so I'm gonna go Bishop takes
his Sykes sir c5 takes takes Queen e2
and now Bishop d6 I get this natural
move here also a6 and I guess not Queen
c7 and then we are changing everything
is on IG 4 move whoa so I think it just
blown there he wanted to go to eat one
but still position was good for us so
I'm gonna go night before exchanging
everything Knight takes hit d3 give me
that Queen a5 you know when I'm material
AB I just want to exchange some pieces
yeah so just the old-school
I take c4 Queen f5 just bring the rook
to c8 and now Queen a4 for example and
Queen a5 you wanna go rooks e7 so whoa
be careful careful
Pepe what better way to celebrate your
last day than with a big victory you
blunder the Queen
you know the mood really changed when we
hit the bullet segment here yeah point
all right village feels like we're
clenched I'm not good at math you're
kind of a math guy yeah what eleven and
a half to six and a half with four games
left
give me clenched I don't know take here
95 then see taxi for just night xe7 so
I'm gonna go native three protecting
this guy and then rooks he wants so he
can't take indeed for now I'm gonna go
upwind III and then I don't know night
taxi seven looks good here I think
what takes III format of this tournament
but I'm not yeah yeah I think I can
attack these points somehow let's just
try to do it like takes takes can I take
on v8 looks great it looks good looks
good looks good and Bishop III is a
threat you shove a three but that's a
good boy I think we should my faith is
coming bishop f8 is coming so give me
that then I take this so let's say Ruby
a group d8 and now Luke c1 I think there
are not so many checks here oh I gotta
be careful I better be careful here Luke
d3 and rook deep and rook c3 that's my
idea here so just root t2 playing a - I
guess I can just go here to c5 to c5
collect this guy whoa
better be careful here I'd better be
careful so Luke f2 Luke f1 some stuff
like that okay one I don't know what's
going on here I think I did something
really stupid in this position so Bishop
a1 we should be for Bishop a1 bishop d4
gotta take this pawn here so Bishop a1 I
think I have to oh my god
Ruka three I'm gonna lose this on time
yes gonna lose this on time come on come
on
no no yeah 843 all right three more
three more yeah yeah yeah let's just get
more points
okay look like you're really good I
think I challenged him already so are
you here yes all right so let's go for
you for me five we should all night okay
I'm gonna go d3 so the fill it up with
the white pieces that should be good
yeah yeah here oh my god okay he didn't
see so I'm gonna go see three I'm gonna
go before I'm gonna go a four and a go
it should be 2 G 3 I think I did
something really stupid but okay Bishop
f1 not the end of the wall again you
should be G to Quincy to knock better be
careful
a tree oh my god I like this I don't
like this at all so what am I doing here
what am I doing here let's play teenage
- prophylaxis prophylaxis against not
afford the bishop belongs to C 1 I don't
know why I moved the Bishop to b2 I know
that but it should be 3 now that we
should be swell place there so route d1
I just try to play some b5 here the
followed by c4 ok let's close everything
takes takes now route comes to case Wow
sacrificing on exchange pretty dangerous
for me actually this position all right
so I'm gonna go a 5 here let's see if I
can close this I are gonna mm-hmm looks
fat looks bad Queen f3 Queen f3 let's go
let's go let's go let's go Kien f2
rookie 1 remove 25 that's it
give me that 92 kena 3G for only 10
seconds from your left that's a little
good
give me that bishop oh my god here
check give me that give me that
oh but alright alright two more yeah
yeah two more on the up by three now at
this point okay so we need like at least
one more point so at least two more
yeahh two more yeahh at least at least
thirteen and a half
that's a good number yeah let's go
alright so I'll try to go for the field
or again t69 f6e five let's see he goes
for the end game no he doesn't you
should see for Bishop e7 g4 I think
that's not very good here I don't
remember the reason I think it you got
to take they're on d4 but then let's say
95 here and then let's say Knight takes
e4 and I'm gonna take on f2 1 I don't
care
so let's say Bishop h4 here it's got to
go there and then takes here and then
probably nine f6 I think I did something
wrong but ok that's a Queen c7 it's
gonna go okay I like that because I got
go long Castle here 97 95 94 that's a
good move d5 now 94 94 it's good
94 is good 94 is good
give me that gonna take this guy got to
go there Knight takes e4 Queen e7 didn't
see that coming
Queen B 8 okay and Queen f4 check Queen
c7 it's got to go there 995 so there's a
fork on c4 let's see he falls for that
no he didn't
Queen c7 I'm gonna go be sick now Kim b8
now there's no 96 97 it's got to go back
check now I managed to exchange the
Queens on the board Knight of 6 rook
takes rook takes Knight takes and think
you can resign but then I haven't known
so much time here so keen e7 here here
give me that
let's run let's run
runty for okay King ghost King ghost
King ghost
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check check tech tech tech
tech tech tech tech tech tech tech tech
tech tech tech tech tech tech tech tech
yeah that's it all right yeah all right
so one more one more
yeah gonna challenge him one more game
and then we're done
I think I have lecture in like yeah wrap
the separate right away at six popular
hopefully get to go eat or something yes
busy day for you last day we're keeping
you busy
ya know but it's been really cool having
you here and you've done quite a lot
all right what's the pleasure for me a
lot of fun so come on it's willing one
more game just get on here yeah so I
think it is he does he think we're done
the last one right
I know okay here we go okay here we go
I'm gonna play now they Potamus okay
yeah a leg down there we go four bullet
because yeah it's you you got many moves
to do horrible Wow okay that'll do it 96
he's going h3 1001 I go Queen e2 we need
to and then we should be free then shot
block castle
Kim b1 a3 and then D for probably Wow d4
I don't want to take that night on so
scared I'm so scared
Bishop f5 so I'm gonna go 94 here to
stop that here give me that Bishop b4 so
d5 has got to go Knight f3
now this not come to h4 probably
then that's a route for free I'm gonna
take that drug and then quit taxi for
his skin is a little bit weak but then
Mike into so I don't know what's going
on here
really so rookie one queen f4 oh my god
oh my god oh this hurts this hurts
okay gotta take that and then and go to
run no I'm just losing good that got me
good exactly okay I can't resign yeah if
the bottommost was not a good choice for
the last game I like it for one minute
game yeah but all right okay all right I
was a lot of fun anyway
yeah we know you got to get off and get
to your classes so it's been a total
pleasure pleasure
jamming res same in your classes tonight
okay thank you and thank you for
everyone for joining yeah thanks
everybody for watching okay see you how
[ __ ] yeah there may be did you dream up
Don's right Danny do you have to hit a
button on this screen
02:5                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                